OKAY VERY GOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'RE GONNA GET THE MEETING
STARTED.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS.
BOB MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL
[inaudible]
THE ROLE [inaudible]
WITH SO.
HERE WAS A PRESENT MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE PRESENT BRADFORD.
PRESENT CHIANG DIED.
PRESENT HERTZBERG ILL.
ILL PRESENT MCGUIRE RUBIO
SKINNER -- PRESENT STERN.
STONE WIENER.
WHEN I PRESENT YOU SAY HERE?
ONE NINE I I WAS CHANGING MY
WAYS [inaudible]
HI.
I'M TRYING TO YEAH AUTO.
GOING ON HERE.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH SB FORTY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER WELCOME.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST I HAPPILY
ACCEPTED COMMITTEES MEMONS
EXCELLENT -- SB FORTY NINE OPENS
THE DOOR FOR THE MANY NEW
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS LIKE
APPS AND SMART FINANCES.
THAT.
CUSTOMERS TO CONNECT WITH THEIR
SMART METERS.
AND CHIEF BETTER ENERGY DEMANDS
MANAGEMENT.
SO WHY IS IT THAT WE NEED BETTER
DEMAND MANAGEMENT.
AS ALL OF US KNOW CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS A 100%.
GOAL TO ACHIEVE.
BE A 100% OF OUR ELECTRICITY
GENERATED FROM RENEWABLE SOURCES.
AS WE ALSO KNOW RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY EXCEPT FOR A FEW OF
LIKE GEO THERMAL IS NOT.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SO IF WE CAN.
MODIFY WHEN ELECTRICITY DEMAND
IS SO WE CAN REDUCE IT PEAK.
THEN WE ARE ABLE TO UTILIZE OUR
RENEWABLE RESOURCES BETTER.
AND HAVE LESS DEPENDENCE ON
FOSSIL FUEL BACK UP.
NOW WHAT IS THE BILL EXPLICITLY
DUE TO OPEN UP THESE OPPORTUNITY.
OUR ENERGY COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY NOW TO SET APPOINT
STANDARDS FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
HOWEVER THEY CANNOT SET
STANDARDS TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
POINTS IS TO BE WHAT WE CALL
SMART.
SO IN OTHER WORDS SO THOSE
APPLIANCES ARE ABLE TO BE
REMOTELY.
IMPACT REMOTELY CONTROLLED OFF
ON LOWERING.
LEFT FOR EXAMPLE WITH AN AIR
CONDITIONER LOWERING THE
TEMPERATURE ARE INCREASING THE
TEMPERATURE OR HOWEVER.
SO WHAT THIS DOES IS ALLOWS THE
CDC TO INCLUDE -- SETTING OF
BUILDING CODE STANDARDS FOR OUR
EXCUSE ME APPLIANCE STANDARDS
FOR DEMAND RESPONSE MEANING
SUPPORTING THOSE SMART
APPLIANCES.
AND CLARIFYING THAT THE CDC CAN
CONSIDER GREENHOUSE GASES
BECAUSE IF THE C. E. C. IN
SETTING THE STANDARDS.
CAN ONLY INCORPORATE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
IT DOES NOT ALLOW.
FOR MOVING DEMAND ISN'T
NECESSARILY A ROOF A A A
REDUCTION IN ELECTRICITY USE
IT'S MORE JUST THE SHIFTING OF
WHEN WE USE THAT ELECTRICITY.
SO THAT'S WHY THE BILL.
ALLOWS THE CDC TO HAVE THAT
OTHER AUTHORITY.
SO I'D LIKE TO HAVE MY WITNESSES
SPEAK I'VE GOT -- LILLIAN
MURDERS FROM OWN CONNECT AN
ERROR IN THE MILLER FROM THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
RESPONSE COUNCIL.
GREAT THANK YELL GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LILLIAN MARVIS I AM A
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH
HOME CONNECT.
OR A RESIDENTIAL DEMAND RESPONSE
A SOFTWARE COMPANY AND WE
SUPPORT SB FORTY NINE I CENTER
SKINNER YOU ACTUALLY.
SAID IT PERFECTLY I COULDN'T
HAVE SAID IT.
HI.
ESSENTIALLY AS MORE NOBLES COME
ONLINE WITH SB FIVE ONE HUNDRED
LIKE CENTER CENTER SAD.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A NEED TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMER DEMAND
MEETS SUPPLY WHEN ITS CLEANNESS
AND WHEN IT'S PREDOMINATELY
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
CURRENTLY A WHAT SB FORTY NINE
PROPOSES IS THAT IT MAKES OF
ISIS SMARTER SO RIGHT NOW THE
WAY DEVICES WORK AS WE TURN
ELECTRONICS ON AND ON BASED ON
WHEN.
WE WANT TO USE ENERGY.
INSTEAD AS BEFORE NINE ENSURES
THAT THESE DEVICES ARE GREAT
CONNECTED AND THEY RESPOND IN
REAL TIME TO GREAT CONDITIONS SO
SPECIFICALLY WHEN THE GREAT IS
ASSN FIND PREDOMINATELY
RENEWABLES.
WHAT OWN CONNECT IS MOSTLY
EXCITED ABOUT IS?
THAT ENSURES THAT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF US IN THIS ROOM HERE
RIGHT NOW CAN BE A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION AND HELP WITH THE
INTEGRATION OF RENEWABLES.
SO EMPOWERS US TO BE A PART OF
THE SMART GRID OF THE FUTURE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THEM THANK YOU.
MR TURN.
GO AHEAD YEAH MR TERM MEMBERS
THEIR NAME A LOT REPRESENTING
THE AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL I FEEL
LIKE IT'S ALL BEEN SAID SO BE
VERY QUICK.
BASICALLY THIS ALLOWS US TO USE
OUR ABUNDANT NATURAL RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE WELL IN ABUNDANCE --
DURING THE DAY SOLAR POWER AND
SHIFTED THAT THE CONSUMER LOAD
ON THE DEMAND SIDE OF THE
EQUATION TO UTILIZE THOSE
RESOURCES IN A WY THAT REDUCES
OR MAINTAINS A LOW GHG PROFILE
AND SO FOR THIS REASON WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU OKAY.
I DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
HOW ABOUT SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION?
WE HAVE SUPPORTER. FOR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
RAISE YOUR HAND ANY OF THOSE
OKAY NONE.
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S A PLEASURE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENT -- DO YOU PASS IS
AMENDED TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE WEST SO I WAS
SO I MORE NOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE.
DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG ILL.
ILL I MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN DOWN -- NO
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- WHEN WE GOT
HERE [inaudible]
ARCHULETA
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MARKET HOW ARE YOU GOOD THANK
YOU.
AND GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- I'M HERE BEFORE YOU --
SB.
SIX SIX TWO AND I'D LIKE TO ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO DO THIS TODAY I HAVE BEFORE
YOU SENATE BILL.
SIX SIX TWO WHICH WOULD ALLOW
INVESTOR OWNED ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES TO MEET THEIR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
MANDATE BY INVESTING IN
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN.
AS A NATION FUEL IN ADDITION TO
THEIR CURRENT SINGULAR
COMPLIANCE PATHWAY.
OF INVESTMENTS IN BATTERY
ELECTRIC CHARGING PROJECTS.
I THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND FROM
DO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
VERY WELL.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTY IMPOSED A MANDATE.
THAT UTILITIES DO THEIR SHARE TO
CLEAN UP OUR TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
AN OVERDUE AND MUCH NEEDED STEP
TO CLEAN UP THE AIR.
THIS BILL MEANT TO GO TO
COMPLEMENT THE GROUND BREAKING
STRIDES MADE BY MADE UNDER SB.
THREE FIFTY BY BRINGING ANOTHER
TECHNOLOGY TO THE FRAY IN A
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL WEAPON TO
OUR ARSENAL INTO THE FIGHT TO
REDUCE RECITATION RELATED
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB SIX SIX TWO DOES NOT IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL MANDATE ON UTILITIES
BUT RATHER ADDS AN ADDITIONAL
COMPLIANCE PATHWAY. FOR THEIR
EXISTING MANDATES.
THIS BILL WITH THE WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT ACCEPTED
TODAY WILL NOT ADD COST TO THE
TAX CODE TO THE RATE PAYERS.
THIS BILL WILL HOWEVER
FACILITATE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
STANCE ON TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AND ALLOW FOR
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY.
TO PLAY A ROLE IN HELPING US
ACHIEVE OUR ADMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE JAKE
DONAHUE AND CAN SENSE AND WITH
BILLARD FUEL SYSTEMS.
AT THE SPONSORED THIS BILL.
AND THEY THEY WILL BE THE
TECHNICAL RESPONSE THAT YOU MAY
HAVE [inaudible]
AND AGAIN -- I THANK VERY WELL
DO YOU HAVE ANY TESTIMONY THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO SHARE.
MISTER.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHECK ON HE
ONLY HAVE BALLARD POWER SYSTEMS
THE SPONSORS SENATE BILL SIX SIX
TWO AS WELL AS SOME LIKE TRANSIT
AGENCY ONE OF THE MANY INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS ON OUR SUPPORTERS
FOR THIS BILL.
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
IN ITS MOST BASIC SENSE IS MEANT
TO MEAN TURNING OUR ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR ZERO
MISSION TECHNOLOGY.
THAT CANNOT BE ACCOMPLISHED WITH
BATTERY ELECTRIC ALONE.
THERE ARE PARTS OF THAT SECTOR
THAT REMAIN UNREACHABLE BY
BATTERY ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY.
INSTEAD HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGY HAS PROVEN THE MOST
FEASIBLE OPTION FOR MANY
OPERATORS IN THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ARENAS SUCH AS BUSES
TRUCKS.
MARINE VESSELS IN LOCOMOTIVES
THE LONG ROUTES OPERATING TIMES
EXTREME TEMPERATURES AND HIGH
TORQUE AND HORSEPOWER NEEDS ARE
JUST A FEW.
REASONS WHY FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY
HAS BEEN NEEDED IN THESE MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY SETTINGS.
WITHOUT INVESTMENTS IN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN THOSE SETTINGS WERE
NEEDS CANNOT BE ADEQUATELY MET
MY BATTERY TECHNOLOGY.
WILL LIKELY BE SETTINGS THAT
REMAIN POWERED BY DIESEL.
AND OTHER NON ZERO MISSION POWER
TRAINS IN STARK CONTRAST TO THE
LEGISLATURE STATED GOALS FOR THE
FUTURE.
WE WANT TO ECHO THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT OF THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH US ON
GETTING THIS BILL IN SHAPE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DIALOGUE.
WITH OUR FRIENDS AT THE AFFECTED
UTILITIES TO NSURE THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS
OF THE AUTHOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE DRY BOTH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I JUST
WANNA.
I BRING THE AMENDMENT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- THE MEMBERS HAVE THE
AMENDMENT ONE OF THEM.
JUST IN CASE SOMEONE AT A MAKE
THE AMENDMENT
.
THE AMENDMENT -- TO THIS BILL
WOULD BE TO AUTHORIZE THE CPUC
TO APPROVE GREEN.
ELECTROLYTIC.
HI HYDROGEN PROPOSALS. TO THE
EXTENT OF THE PROS POLLS ARE
COST EFFECTIVE PAIRS HELP MEET
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS.
AND DO NOT RESULT IN DUPLICATIVE
INVESTMENTS.
AS THE MEN.
THAT WERE SUGGESTING THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED.
THOSE IN THE PUBLIC.
WHO ARE NOT PRIVY TO THAT
AMENDMENT WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE?
YOU AWARE.
OF SUPPORTERS OF THE MEASURE MAY --
YES ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TIM SAYS SCENE WITH
BALLARD FUEL CELL SYSTEMS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT OF BALLARD THE GLOBAL
LEADER IN FUEL CELL
MANUFACTURING FOR TRANSPORTATION
APPLICATIONS SEPARATE
CELEBRATING OUR FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY THIS YEAR. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
REGARDING HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
INDUSTRY WE HAVE A SPONSOR THIS.
AND BELIEVE THAT IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO BRING PARITY IN
CALIFORNIA ZERO MISSION
INVESTMENT IN TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS VISION AND PRESSING THE
VITAL ROLE THAT HIGH HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY MUST PLAY
IN CALIFORNIA'S EFORTS TO
TRANSFORM HIS TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO
BE HERE AS A RESOURCE AND ALONG
WITH THE AUTHOR MY COLLEAGUE IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
WELL WE'RE GONNA BRING.
IN FAVOR SPEAKERS [inaudible]
NONE.
ARE YOU IN FAVOR.
BASKETBALL CAN BE AT THE CENTER
OF TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENT --
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
NURTURED.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROXANA BACK ON HOW MANY WITH
MANACOR ADVOCACY -- I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN GATE AND AS
ZERO EMISSION MARINE AS WELL AS
RED WHITE FLEET.
THEY ARE END USERS IN
MANUFACTURES ZERO EMISSION
VESSELS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VALERIE
TURN LOVE Là HOSE WITH PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY.
WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION WE ARE VERY EXCITED
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS BROUGHT THIS
BILL FORWARD THERE'S A LOT OF
HYDROGEN WORK GOING ON HERE AND
GLOBALLY -- BUT WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT -- THE HYDROGEN
INITIATIVES ARE CONSIDERED IN
THIS BILL COMPLEMENT AND DON'T
COMPETE WITH OUR TURNED.
I'M GOALS SO -- TO SEE SOME OF
THE COST EFFECTIVE AND REPAIR
PROTECTIONS -- IN THE BILL -- WE
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE IT AS A
MANDATE -- AND FINALLY WE WE ARE
PLEASE AT THE AUTHOR IS --
PROPOSING A TECH TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL -- APPROACH TO THIS NAY
SENT -- TECHNOLOGY WE'RE PLEASED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- AT THE AUTHOR AND
THE AND THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
I SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND IF WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM
HERE ON THE DIES.
GOOD MORNING HERE IN WESTERN
MEMBERS -- NEEDED FOR THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MEMBERS IN EVERY
SECTOR OF THE ARE IN G. INDUSTRY
INCLUDING ORGANIZED LABOR.
UTILITIES AND THE PRODUCERS OF
OVER 90% OF THAT RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS IN NORTH AMERICA --
WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVE A TWEENER
POSITION TODAY WERE NOT AN
OFFICIAL -- OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WE'RE HOPING TO WORK
THROUGH THIS ISSUE I'M WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND WE AGREE WITH CENTER ARE TO
LET ITS GOAL.
OF ADDING HYDROGEN TO STATUTES
THAT INCENTIVIZE THE USE IT'S
YOUR MISSION VEHICLES -- BUT AS
YOU'RE ACTUALLY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE
DEFINITION IN THIS BILL.
EXCLUDES SEVERAL OTHER FORMS OF
RENEWABLE AND NON FOSSEL
HYDROGEN MANY OF THEM -- ARE
MORE MATURE AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE INCLUDING -- RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN MADE FROM RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS WHO ARE THE FOLKS
THAT I REPRESENT [inaudible]
I'M.
AS FOR ME GIVE ME NOW SAYS ALSO
POINTS OUT THE CARBON INTENSITY
OF THIS YOU'LL HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO VERY WIDELY ACCORDING TO FEED
STOCK.
I'M SOME OF THAT MAY BE TAKEN
CARE OF BY THE AMENDMENTS BUT
THE IRONY HERE IS THAT BY
EXCLUDING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
ARE ACTUALLY.
EXCLUDING HYDROGEN THAT HAS A
NEGATIVE CARBON INTENSITY AND
LIMITING IT ONLY TWO ZERO
THEREFORE ANY CONFLICTING WITH
OUR AYE MICHAELS AND SO.
OUT WE WOULD ASK THAT THIS.
BILL BE CHANGED.
TO INCLUDE SOME OF THESE OTHER
FORMS OF RENEWABLE NON POSSO
HYDROGEN EITHER BY CALLING IT
OUT THAT WAY OR ANOTHER WAYS
THAT IT'S NOT LIMITED TO ONLY
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY VERY WELL OF COMMITTEE.
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU.
I'M I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL I AM.
WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT
LAST YEAR ALLOWED US TO TREAT A
DEFINITION OF GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
ARTESIAN.
I DO THINK THAT THE POINT AROUND
THE OTHER ëEWABLE
HYDROGEN.
ALLOWING THEM TO BE USED IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
IS A VALID POINT.
AND I THINK THAT IS WORTH THE
AUTHORS.
I IN SPONSOR'S CONSIDERATION I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD HANG THE
BILL UP NOW BUT I THINK THAT IS
A VERY WORTHWHILE CONSIDERATION.
ON AND I AM ALSO I UNDERSTAND
WHY THE DEVELOPMENT OF HYDROGEN
AS A CLEAN -- EITHER ELECTRICITY
GENERATION SOURCE OR
TRANSPORTATION SOURCE GOT HUNG
UP.
BECAUSE FOR YEARS WE WHEN --
RENEWABLE BASED ELECTRICITY WAS
VERY HIGH COST.
IT WAS NOT COST EFFECTIVE TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN TO THAT MEANS
AND WE WERE MOSTL PRODUCING
HYDROGEN THROUGH.
A POSSIBLE FROM A LOSS OF YOUR
POWER SOURCE SO IN FACT WE WERE
NOT GETTING MUCH PARDON BENEFIT
FROM HYDROGEN.
BUT NOW WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY UTILIZE IT IN FACT.
ANYTIME WERE OVER GENERATING
ELECTRICITY.
I'M THAT IS GENERATED FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES IT ALLOWS US
NOW TO PRODUCE HYDROGEN WHICH
CAN THEN SUPPLANT.
ANY FOSSIL FUEL WHETHER IT'S IN
TRANSPORTATION OR OTHER WHICH IS
REALLY THE TYPE OF CLEAN ENERGY
DIVERSITY WE WANT TO ACHIEVE.
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND
INTERESTINGLY.
I USED TO RUN A PROJECT THAT --
WAS PROMOTING THESE KINDS OF
THINGS AND BACK IN -- NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WE DID A
DEMONSTRATION OF BALLARD FUEL
CELL BUSES IN CHICAGO.
AND THEN MAYOR DALEY CUP UNDER
THE BE A TAIL PIPE.
AND DRINK THE EMISSIONS SO THAT
WAS ONE TV.
UNFORTUNATELY ARJUN FUEL CELL
BUSES DID NOT TAKE OFF THE WAY I
THINK SOME OF US HOPE BUT WE WE
ARE SEEING THAT TECHNOLOGY.
A VERY VERY AVAILABLE AND WE ARE
SEEING NOW THE ABILITY TO POWER
IT WITH OUR RENEWABLE SOURCES SO
WITH THAT I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT
SENATOR YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS
WILL NOT ADD COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
BUT MY RESEARCH IS SHOWING THAT
IT WILL SO DID YOU.
HELP EXPLAIN BERMAN TURNOUT DOES
IT TO THAT THE TECHNICIAN HERE.
AND YOU CAN AFTER THAT.
CERTAINLY YEAH THE KEY HERE IS
PRODUCTION OF ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN AT A UTILITY SCALE SO
AS WE CAN PRODUCE HYDROGEN FROM
ELECTRICITY COSTED BELOW FIVE
CENTS A KILOWATT HOUR WHICH YOU
CAN ACHIEVE. FOR PEAVEY AND WIN
INSTALLATIONS GREATER THAN A
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS YOU GET TO
HYDROGEN THAT'S PRODUCED AT
BELOW PARITY COMPARED TO
ELECTRICAL RESOURCES EVEN WHEN
YOU KHôNG CAPITAL.
AMORTIZED OVER TEN YEARS THAT AS
ABOUT FIFTY CENTS PER KILOGRAM
SO BECOMES QUITE AFFORDABLE.
THE KEY POINT FOR
ELECTRIFICATION WE LOOK AT SB.
ONE HUNDRED MOVING UP TO TWENTY
FORTY FIVE FULL EDUCATION WE
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
QUINN OPPLE OR QUADRUPLE THE
RENEWABLE GENERATION.
IN CALIFORNIA IF WE DO THAT ALL
WITH LITHIUM ION TECHNOLOGY
WE'RE LOKING AT ELECTRIFYING
AREAS OF THE GRID THAT ARE
ALREADY VERY ENERGY INTENSE LIKE
THE LA BASIN.
LIKE THE BAY AREA DOING THAT
COST EFFECTIVELY AND IN WAYS
THAT DO NOT INCREASE
SUSCEPTIBILITY TO WILDFIRES
OUTAGES IS GONNA BE VERY
CHALLENGING AND IT'S WORTHWHILE
FOR THE UTILITIES TO HAVE THE
OPTION. FOR PRODUCING FUEL IN
REMOTE AREAS FROM NEW
INSTALLATIONS OF WIND AND SOLAR
AND BEING ABLE TO MOVE THOSE IN
WAYS THAT DON'T REQUIRE NEW HIGH
TENSION LINES NEW.
TRANSMISSION DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AREAS WHERE IT
MAKES SENSE.
AND IN THAT WAY IT'S GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE FOR HE
RATE PAYERS TO HAVE THOSE
OPTIONS AT THEIR DISPOSAL SO THE
ANSWER IS MAYBE.
THE ANSWER IS A DEFINITE YES.
WE HAVE THE ALTERNATIVE AD
RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDED A HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO MILLION WHAT WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THAT PROGRAM.
SO THE CDC HAS FUNDED A NUMBER
OF INITIATIVES IN IN RESPECT TO
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION --
THEY HAVE.
FUNDED PRIMARILY -- BATTERY
ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGIES AND THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING THAT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SINCE -- THAT
INITIATIVE PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN FUNDING THAT PROGRAM AT CC.
SO THEY HAVE BEEN ON AN ONGOING
BASIS FUNDING PROGRAMS RELATING
TO BATTERY ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND SOME.
IN THE HYDROGEN SPACES WELL BUT
THE DISPARITY AND THE GAP IS
WIDE LOOKING AT ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION TOTAL STATEWIDE
INVESTMENTS IN BATTERY ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGY.
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION IN HYDROGEN -- AND
THAT'S NOT GOING TO GET US TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE IN ORDER FOR
HYDROGEN TO FILL THOSE GAPS THAT
WERE MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AS ONE OF BLOOD YOU.
FOR IT WAS SOME SOLUTION.
WHEN THINGS ON THE TABLE I MEAN
YOU KNOW?
IN WHERE YOU ARE YOU REPRESENT.
PARTS LA I REPRESENT.
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE COUNTRY.
I THINK WE'RE THE RICHEST STATE
IN IN THE WORLD AND YET.
KIDS YOU'RE GOING TO SCHOOL WITH
ASTHMA EVERY DAY NUMBER ONE
BECAUSE IT'S WELL SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW.
IS CHILDHOOD ASKED SO THIS EVEN
TO PUT THIS KIND OF TECH
SOLUTION FOR AYE AYE WHY ONE OF
BY JOHN IT.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE YOU WORK HARD
FOR YOU FOLKS THIS WILL BENEFIT.
ALL CALIFORNIA -- SO I'D LOVE
THE SENATE AS A CO AUTHOR IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IN JUST
APPRECIATE YOU.
PUT IN SOME WHEN YOUR SHOULDER
THAT WE ON THIS PLANE
TRANSPORTATION PUZZLE BECAUSE
IT'S GONNA BE HARD TO SOLVE AND
AND REPORTS OF LA ALL THROUGH
THAT SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR AND ALL
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE SOUTH LND
LIKE THIS STUFF IS HARD AND
HEAVY DUTY SIZE OF TOUGH PUZZLE
TO SOLVE.
AND IT'S NOT THE SAME WAYS ALL
THE LIKE DO SO.
I APPRECIATE THE DIVERSITY
TECHNOLOGY BOARD AND LEAD TO
JOIN HIS PARTNER.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- JUST GENERALLY --
CONCERNING THE THE THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE RECENTLY MADE -- BY --
BY BUT THE BIO GAS ASSOCIATION
IT WOULD BEHOOVE US AS THE STATE
TO INCLUDE ALL.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR OUR EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS -- AND WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD A POLICY IN THE STATE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO BE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL SO I THINK IT
WOULD BE YOU'D BE WELL SERVED
WE'D ALL BE WELL SERVED IF YOU
WORK WITH THAT ASSOCIATION SEE
HOW.
THAT CAN BE ADDRESSED -- WE
DIDN'T COMPLETELY.
ADDRESS IT WITH OUR COMMITTEE --
AMENDMENTS I THINK THEY GO A
LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING NOT BUT
NOT.
IF THERE IS ANYTHING THAT WAS
LEFT OUT MAYBE YOU CAN WORK THAT
OUT FOR INFO ON A GOING FORWARD
BASIS I THINK THAT'LL HELP YOU.
DOWN THE ROAD. TO GET THIS BILL
TO THE GOVERNOR'S TASK.
BECAUSE THAT'S GENERALLY HOW --
OUR STATE HAS LINED UP ANYWAY
IT'S JUST A VERY -- CONSISTENT
POLICY THAT WE'VE APPROVED HERE --
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION --
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HE PASSES AMENDED TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WEST SO.
I WAS SO I AM MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
DODD AYE DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
THE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE.
STONE NO WIENER WIENER AYE. SIX
ONE OKAY WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE
ROLE OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW IF WE CAN HAVE CENTER DOT.
SURE THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE THE I.
BOLT THANK YOU
.
SENATOR DR NUMBER YEAR YES NO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EXTREME
WEATHER IS INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IN THE LAKE TO THE WILDFIRE
SEASON.
YEARS OF DROUGHT RESULTING IN
MILLIONS OF DEAD TREES FOLLOWED
BY SUBSTANTIAL VEGETATION GROWTH
DURING A RECORD SET A WET WINTER.
BECAME WILDFIRE FUEL DURING
RECORD SETTING HEAT VERY LOW
HUMIDITY AND VERY HIGH WINDS.
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE TWELVE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES IN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WERE CAUSED BY ELECTRIC POWER IN
DISTRIBUTION LIVES CONDUCTORS
AND POWER POLES.
CAL FIRE CITED TREES OR PARTS OF
TREES FALLING ON THE POWER LINES
AS SPECIFIC CLAUSES OF THE FIRES.
ADEQUATE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCING THE RISK
OF TREES AND BRUSH CONTACTING
ELECTRIC LINES AND EQUIPMENT.
PART OF CALPERS MISSION IS TO
PREVENT FIRES CAL FIRE FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM INCLUDES
WILDLAND FIRE.
SKEWS ME WILD LAND THREE FIRE
ENGINEERING.
IN MANAGEMENT FIRE PLANNING
EDUCATION AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
CAL FIRE UNIQUELY SITUATED TO
DETERMINE WHAT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS NECESSARY TO
REDUCE THE LEVEL WHILE FAR REST
FROM CONTACT WITH THE LET'S
CLIENTS.
IN A QUICK BIT.
ADD TO ENSURE THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS SUFFICIENTLY
IMPLEMENTED.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
CAL FIRE TO PROVIDE EACH
ELECTRICAL CORPORATION WITH A
LIST OF ALL TREES AND OTHER
VEGETATION TO BE REMOVED OR TRAM.
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CPC AND OTHER LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
AND REDUCE THE LEVEL WILD FIRE
RISK.
FROM CONTACT WITH ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS ELECTRIC LINES AND
EQUIPMENT.
HOW FAR WOULD ALSO ON EACH
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH CAL FIRES
LIST?
THIS IS MORE WORK FOR CAL FIRE
THE CALIFORNIA BE REIMBURSED.
BY THE UTILITY FOR ALL ITS COST
INCLUDING ANY NEW RESOURCES
NEEDED SO IT'S ABILITY TO
PERFORM ITS OTHER DUTIES.
WILL NOT BE IMPAIRED.
MILEY BECAUSE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK IS VERY
DANGEROUS.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN ALSO REQUIRES
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WORK
BE PERFORMED BY QUALIFIED LYING%
CLEARANCE TREE TRIMMERS OR
CLARENCE STREET DRUMMER TRAINEES.
JUST THE OTHER DAY JUDGE ELSA
OVERSEEING P. GENIES PROBATION
IN THE SAN BRUNO CASE SAID.
P. JEANNIE HAS NOT CUT THE RIGHT
TREES.
IN RESPONSE P. JEANNIE SAID AND
I QUOTE.
THERE'S A LOT OF TREES OUT THERE
AND WE DON'T HAVE EYES ON ALL OF
THEM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
SUBMIT LET'S GIVE THE ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES THE EYES THEY NEED TO
ADEQUATELY MANAGE VEGETATION.
AND CUT THE RIGHT TREES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REMEMBER SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
WE'RE WORKING SPONSORING THE
BILL WITH WITH SENATOR DODD.
WE BELIEVE WE REPRESENT ALL OF
THE LINE CLEAR IT'S A TREE
TRIMMERS IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT -- TECHNICIANS FOR
ALL THREE THE UTILITIES.
WE ALSO REPRESENT THE FOLKS WHO
DO THESE INSPECTIONS.
SO SHIFTING THIS RESPONSIBILITY
FROM THE UTILITY. TO CAL FIRE
ACTUALLY COST US JOBS.
BUT WE THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO [inaudible]
BECAUSE AS WE SAW SEVENTEEN
FIRES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WERE DETERMINED BY CAL FIRE TO
HAVE BEEN CAUSED BECAUSE IN
THEIR VIEW.
THERE WAS AN APPROPRIATE TREE
CLEARANCE IT WAS PERFORMED BY
THE COMPANY AND SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A RESPONSE.
A RESPONSIBLE WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT [inaudible]
SECONDLY.
ON THE THE THE HE WORK FORCE
THAT WE THAT WE REPRESENT IN THE
TREE TRIMMING AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
IS A MOSTLY IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE
IT'S A LOW WAGE WORKFORCE
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND THEIR SUFFERING.
GREAT HARM [inaudible]
AN ABUSE.
NOT BUT UTILITIES BUT BY MANY OF
THE SECOND AND THIRD TIER
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT ARE
CONTRACTED TO GO OUT AND DO THE
TREE TRIMMING.
AND BRUSH CLEARANCE.
WE'VE GONE FROM HAVING A
THOUSAND MEMBERS WORKING IN THAT
AREA AT P. JEANNIE. TO TH OVER
THREE THOUSAND IN SIX MONTHS
THAT'S HOW QUICKLY THEY'VE BEEN
HIRING THAT CONTRACTORS ARE
COMING FROM OTHER STATES
LITERALLY.
WITH LIKE TWENTY TRUCKS AND NO
EMPLOYEES.
AND WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THEY SHOW UP AND GOT A FULL CREW.
THESE WORKERS ARE NOT BEING
TRAINED APPROPRIATELY.
HOPING TO GET THE LATEST
INFORMATION AND DATA FROM CAL
OSHA.
BUT THE NUMBERS ARE ALARMING
FROM OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWELVE TO
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY FOURTEEN
THAT'S LESS THAN TWO YEARS.
SEVENTY FOUR SERIOUS ACCIDENTS.
FIFTY FOUR REQUIRING
HOSPITALIZATION.
AND ELEVEN DEATHS.
OUR INTERNAL RECORDS INDICATE
THAT THOSE NUMBERS.
ARE A LITTLE FAR FEWER THAN
WHAT'S OCCURRED IN THE LAST
SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
BECAUSE THIS IS A MIGRANT
WORKFORCE.
OF AB PREDOMINATELY SPANISH
SPEAKING.
THE NUMBER OF ACCIDENTS GO
WOEFULLY UNDER REPORTED BECAUSE
OF INTIMIDATION FROM THE
CONTRACTORS.
OR FEAR FOR THEIR FAMILIES IF
THEY HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
SO THIS WORK FORCE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS THEY GO OUT INTO
THE WOODS.
AND THEY HAVE SOME NEW HIRE WHO
SUPPOSED TO ONLY BE CLEARING
BRUSH [inaudible]
HAULING DEBRIS.
AND ONCE THEY GET A LIKE
BACKWARDS THE CONTRACTOR
HANDSOME CHAINSAW IS AS GO CUT
SOME TREES.
WE HAVE A MEMBER OF OURS DIE
BECAUSE OF LACK OF TRAINING JUST
A MONTH AGO.
FROM PULLING A TREE OVER ON
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
REALIZE THE APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS TO DO THAT SO WITH THE
WITH THE SENATORS LEGISLATION
WOULD DO.
IS REQUIRE THE UTILITIES TO
INVEST MONEY INTO TRAINING OF
THESE WORKERS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY GO OUT INTO THE WOODS AND
THAT THEY'RE SAFER.
AND ALSO EDUCATE THEM ABOUT OUR
WORKERS COMP LAWS AND HOW THEY
REPORT ACCIDENTS -- IS WHICH
THIS IS A CRITICAL BECAUSE THIS
WORKFORCE IS BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THANK YOU.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY IN PLACE
AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OR A VERY WELL --
SUPPORTERS ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
SUPPORTERS OF YOU CAN MAKE YOUR
WAY TO THE MIKE NOW.
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M KAREN MILLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN FACT WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL.
BEEN WORKING WITH THE UTHORS
OFFICE IN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE DIALOGUE WE HAVE WITH THE
OFFICE -- TWO THERE ARE CONCERNS
AND REFLECT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD.
COUNTENANCE ON ALL TREES IN THE
SERVICE TERRITORIES WHICH
INCLUDES ORCHARD TREES WHICH ARE
MEMBERS -- HAVE AN ABUNDANCE
SEVEN ARE DISSECTED BY
DISTRIBUTION TRANSMISSION.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPONENTS OF THIS [inaudible]
NO.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY'S WITH RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING -- UNFORTUNATELY HAVING
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED --
POSITION ON THIS BILL OUR MEMBER
COUNTIES HAVE THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE STATE'S WORST LANDS IN
THE BORN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE CAST CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
IN RECENT YEARS SO WE'RE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS
TO REDUCE WILD VIRUS.
WE SUPPORT THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
WHEN IT COMES TO AUDITING
UTILITIES VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND EVEN SEE UTILITY
FOR SOME TYPE OF TREMULOUS BUT
WE THINK THE BILL IS A BIT OF A
REACH.
WE DON'T THINK THAT CAL FIRE IS
THE RESPONSIBLE ENTITY AND THE
APPROPRIATE INTO.
PREPARING A COMPREHENSIVE TERM
WEST FOR EVERY UTILITY WHO HAS --
WE THINK THE UTILITIES HAVE
EVERY INCENTIVE TO GO OUT
INSPECT THEIR LINES MAKE SURE
THEY'RE TRIMMING THE VEGETATION
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T AND
THEY'RE NOT ACTING REASONABLY
AND PRUDENTLY.
RIGHT THERE.
THEY BEAR SAID STAND FOR US SO
WE THINK THERE IS UTILITY FOR A
SCALED BACK FROM WEST HOW FIRES
OUT EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE THE
CORE MISSION FUNCTIONS.
ASIDE FROM FIGHTING WILDFIRES
ARE GOING TO BE DOING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTIONS AND HESITATION
MANAGE.
WHEN THEY'RE OUT IN -- THEIR
TERRITORIES DOING INSPECTIONS
DOING WORK THAT'S WHEN THEY CAN
pTHAT'S AND CROUCHING.
UPON UTILITY LINES LOG THOSE AND
SUBMIT THEM TO THE APPROPRIATE
CHILI KIND OF LIKE A MANDATED
REPORTER SAYS YES WE THINK THAT
WOULD PRESERVE THEIR SCARCE
RESOURCES FOR THESE OTHER CORE
FUNCTIONS.
AND STILL ACCOMMODATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS -- TO ATTAIN
THIS AUDIT FUNCTION WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE WORKER SAFETY
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL -- ANY
THE OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
WE JUST ARE AFRAID THAT THIS
WILL ROAD CAL FIRES RESOURCES
AND FOCUSED ON THESE
RESPONSIBILITY OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY -- WELL YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS -- IN THE
NUMEROUS HEARINGS.
AND WE ARE GIVING CAL FIRE MORE
RESOURCES AND WE JUST TO PROVE A
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET -- FOR
THE STATE'S READINESS STATEWIDE
AND THE IDEA IS GONNA BE TWO IN
ADDITION TO THAT EQUIPMENT TO
HIRE MORE PEOPLE IN THIS BILL
HAS A PROVISION. TO ACTUALLY PAY
FOR THOSE SERVICES SO I MEAN.
ONE THING THAT I'VE LEARNED
ABOUT THE STATE IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE.
A CONSISTENT -- WE DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES SPREAD OUT
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE STATE WE
HAVE SOME AREAS THAT ARE.
MUCH MORE PREPARED OTHERS ARE
NOT AND WE WILL WE HAVE -- TO DO
MORE. TO PROVIDE.
CONSISTENT COVERAGE ACROSS THE
STATE I THINK THIS BILL WILL DO
AN ENORMOUS -- A GOOD IN
ACCOMPLISHING NOT SO -- YOU.
ARE ACCEPTING OR AMENDMENT BUT
YOU'RE ALSO POSE IN ANOTHER
AMENDMENT.
IN ADDITION TO OURS ARTISTS AS
TO REQUIRE THIS TO BE SEATED
DETERMINE WHETHER.
A TWO WAY BALANCING ACCOUNT IS
NECESSARY.
AND YOU ALSO WANTED INCLUDE IF
THE ELECTRICAL CORPORATION
EXCEEDED SOUTH RISE REVENUES FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT SHALL
IMMEDIATELY NOTICE.
THE COMMISSION ON THE COMMISSION
MAY.
REQUIRE THE ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION SEES VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK.
DO YOU SEE I MEAN.
YOU SEE AN AN I THINK THAT'S WE
ARE YOU REASONABLE DO YOU THINK
THAT.
DO YOU THINK THAT I WILL BUT YOU
THINK THIS AMENDMENTS EVEN
NECESSARY JUST SEEMS IF IF.
IF WHAT WAS.
A LOT IT TO YOU FOR VIRGIN
STATION MANAGEMENT.
RUNS OUT.
YOU'RE EITHER GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE COMMISSION REQUESTS MORE
REVENUES ORG LET THEM KNOW WE
RAN OUT YET IS THAT RIGHT YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU WE
WERE SUGGESTING THAT AS A A MORE
PRACTICAL.
WAY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THIS
RACE IN THE ANALYSIS SO WHEN YOU
HAVE A TWO WAY BOUNCING ACCOUNT.
IF YOU DON'T SPEND ALL YOUR
FUNDS THEN THEN YOU HAVE TO YOUR
RECEIPT BACK TO TO THE TO THE
COMMISSION.
IF IF YOU.
SEED YOUR FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED YOU CAN KEEP GOING
BECAUSE IT'S NECESSARY WORK FOR
FOR FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
PURPOSES -- WHAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING IS INSTEAD OF THE
MOMENT IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS IS
TO REQUIRE THAT THE UTILITY THE
MOMENT THEY?
USE UTILIZE ALL THEIR FUNDS THEY
NOTICED NOTIFY THE COMMISSION.
AND EXPLICITLY GIVE THE
COMMISSION THE POWER TO SAY STOP
WHAT YOU'RE DOING UNTIL WE
APPROVE MORE FUNDS BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IS SLOW THEM DOWN AND
HAVE THEM YOU KNOW PULL BACK TO
CREWS THAT ARE DOING THIS
CRITICAL WORK.
BUT WE WE ALSO WELL.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS ABOUT TO SAY
WE DON'T WANT TO STOP
[inaudible]
THE WORK.
HAVE TO RESORT.
TO A REGULATORY PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AND REMEMBER THE
UTILITY DOESN'T MAKE ANY MONEY
OFF OF THE FUNDS.
STATION MANAGER MEANING THEY
DON'T GET YOU KNOW A PERCENTAGE --
RETURN ON THAT AT ALL IT JUST
IT'S DOLLAR IN GOES DOLLAR OUT
TO THE WORK AT HAND -- WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT WE JUST ONE ON ONE
TO REVIEW AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT.
ACCOMPLISHES WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- ANYONE ELSE.
WILL MOVE BILL YOU NEED TO SAY
SOMETHING.
TO I THINK IT'S IT'S COMING IN
MY COMMITTEE I'LL BE SUPPORTING
TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED TO LAY A
LITTLE BIT A GROUP GROUNDWORK.
I WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT HOW
THIS WOULD IMPACT IN THE NON
TREAT.
WE'RE THE WE'RE BIG TREES AREN'T
THE ISSUE.
I WANT TO I WANT TO KNOW MORE
MAYBE THIS IS FOR THE UTILITY --
REPRESENTATIVE HERE BUT WHAT IS
IT WHAT IS THIS WORK LOOK LIKE
IN THE SOUTH LAND IN THE
CHAPARRAL ANOTHER SHOULD NOT.
WE'RE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT SORT
OF A DIFFERENT.
PUZZLE THAN JUST ABOUT TO TREAT
THE TRIM LIST.
JUST CURIOUS OKAY SO -- SO THE
THE THE REGULATION REQUIRES THE
UTILITY TO CLEAR FOR TWELVE FEET
AROUND THE LINE.
BUT THEN THE RESOURCES CODE GOES
ON TO SAY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU HAVE TO
CLEAR ANY TREE.
OR VEGETATION THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY.
BECAUSE A INCIDENT SO YOU -- SO
THAT'S WHERE CAL FIRE COMES INTO
EFFECT BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE AS
HE AS A WITH OUR CREWS GO OUT
THEY GET INTO THIS VERY.
A STICKY SITUATION THEY THERE'S
THE THE THE TREES AND HE'D BE
CLEAR CLEARLY WITHIN THE TWELVE
FOOT RANGE BUT THEN THERE'S
TREES ON A JOINING PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
THAT.
UNDER THE RESOURCES CODE THE
UTILITIES OBLIGATED TO GO AND
CUT IF THEY THINK COULD
POTENTIALLY IN IN IN IN IN IN
THE EVENT.
INTERSECT WITH THE LINES THAT'S
A VERY SUBJECTIVE THING.
PROPERTY OWNERS OF THEY DON'T
TAKE TOO KINDLY TO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE ALL OF A SUDDEN GOING ON
TO THEIR PROPERTY TO CUT A TREE.
THAT IS NOT DIRECTLY DIRECTLY
WITHIN THAT TWELVE FOOT RADIUS
AND SO THAT'S A PROBLEM WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND WE DEAL REALLY ANGRY.
YEAH I HAVE -- TO SO YEAH AND I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CLOSE IT
HERE BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING IN THAT AND THAT I JUST
WANT TO KNOW THE THE ON THE TWO
WAY ACCOUNT THOUGH THAT YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT -- THE WHAT'S THE
PLAN THERE WHAT WHAT HOW ARE YOU
PRECEDING HERE AND IT'S SORT OF
WHAT'S THE MAN OKAY IF.
WE DON'T WANT TO WORK.
AND MY CONCERN WITH THE STOP AT
THIS MOMENT.
SO WE JUST WANNA LOOK AT THIS A
LITTLE BIT MORE IF IF IF THAT IS
THE CASE IF THIS ACCOMPLISHES
WHAT WE BOTH WANT.
WILL ACCEPT THIS AMENDMENT.
IN IN EXCHANGE FOR THE OTHER SO --
IF YOU WANT.
TO MOTION WE GET A MOTION
CLOSING WE ASK DR A COOK -- YEAH
YEAH I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
THANK GOD I JUST HAD SOME
CONCERNS SENATOR DODD -- THIS IS
A A VERY -- SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATION THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE TAKEN CARE OF FIRE SAFETY.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING ABOUT
MAYBE SOME MISSION CREEP FOR IT
BEING EXPENSIVE INVENTORY TAKER
FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT WE
ALREADY -- PROVIDE FOR AND I'M.
I'M I'M WONDERING IF TWO THINGS
ONE IS WHEN THEY'RE OUT THERE
DURING THE INVENTORY AND MARY
SEES BABY AT A SEVERE CONDITION.
ARE THEY PERMITTED IN AT THAT
TIME JUST TO TAKE CARE OF IT.
OR OR DO THEY HAVE TO CALL IT IN
SAY HEY SEND A CREW [inaudible]
THE EXPERTS.
UP WITH WELL CURRENTLY WHAT
HAPPENS IS -- TO A CONTRACTOR
USUALLY IT'S NOT EMPLOYEES OF
PGD BUT I CONTRACT LIKE DAVEY
TREES.
WILL GO OUT AND DO A PRE CUT --
INVENTORY IN A PARTICULAR ZONE
AND IDENTIFY ALL OF THE TREES IT
NEED TO BE TRAINED AND AND
MANAGE -- THEY DO HAVE THE
ABILITY IF THEY SEE SOMETHING
THAT IS CREATE WOULD CREATE AN
IMMINENT -- POTENTIAL FOR AN
INCIDENT. TO FLAG THAT AND THEN --
YOU KNOW THE BIG THE COMPANY CAN
MAKE THE DECISION TO SEND A CREW
OUT IMMEDIATELY TO ADDRESS THAT
IF THEY IF THEY DEEM IT AT THAT
LEVEL THEY DO HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY BUT TYPICALLY.
THEY DO THE THE THE THE GRID FOR
THE ZONE.
THEN THE UTILITY WILL THEN HIRE
ANOTHER CONTRACTOR TO GO OUT AND
ACTUALLY CLEAR THOSE TREES AND
THEN THE CONTRACTOR THE DID THE
INSPECTION GOES BACK OUT AND
INSPECTS AND SAYS YEAH.
THE ADEQUATELY ACCOMPLISHED WHAT
WE INTENDED THEM TO DO MR WHICH
JUST YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY MY BIGGEST
CONCERN YOU'VE ALREADY GOT.
A CONTRACTOR COMING IN AND DOING
THE INVENTORY AND NOW YOU'RE
SAYING WE WANT CAL FIE TO DO
THAT INVENTORY AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY THAT'S A SMART
MOVE WHEN WE'RE READY.
WELL BECAUSE THERE THE FIRE
EXPERTS.
THEY HAVE GREATER EXPERTISE THEN
A CONTRACTOR PERHAPS A
CONTRACTOR WHO JUST COME TO
CALIFORNIA FROM ARIZONA OR
NEVADA.
AND THERE THE FIRE EXPERTS
THEY'RE THE ONES WE SEND IN POST
FIRE TO DETERMINE.
IF THE TREES WERE APPROPRIATELY --
TRIMMED AND MAINTAINED SO IT
JUST MAKES SENSE AT LEAST TO TO
US THAT THEY WOULD BE THE BEST
SOURCE TO GO IN AHEAD OF TIME.
FOR PREVENTIVE MEASURES AND
IDENTIFY THE TREES THATTHEY
BELIEVE WOULD CREATE THE BIGGEST
RISK FOR THEM HAVING SAID THAT
WOULD THAT CREATE A LIABILITY
EXPOSURE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WELL IT DOESN'T SHIP IT DOESN'T
SHIFT TO THE ALLIED ABILITY
SENATOR BECAUSE UNDER INVERSE
CONDEMNATION UTILITY.
IS ON THE HOOK REGARDLESS IF --
IF A FIRE IS CREATED BY A PIECE
OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE THERE THERE COULD BE SOME
SOME NEW IT CONFERRED LIABILITY
WE'RE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW WE
PROTECT YOUR INDEMNIFY -- CAL
FIRE IN THOSE INSTANCES -- SO
THAT'S DEFINITELY A SOMETHING
THAT IS IS BEING WORKED ON BUT
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE LIABILITY
OF THE UTILITY BECAUSE OF
INVERSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
OKAY A CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
CLOSING [inaudible]
YES.
ADD TO PASS TO BE AMENDED AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER WAS
SO BY.
WITH SO I MORE LOCK.
EFFORT.
BRADFORD I CHING.
CHANG AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE
HERTZBERG.
HILL [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
RUBIO.
pSKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
STONE STONE NO WIENER.
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG AYE [inaudible]
CENTER WHERE [inaudible] NINE
NINE TO ONE WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ROLL OPEN PRESS MEMBERS.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO TO SEE IF YOU
COULD GIVE SOME BRIEF OPENING
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT YOUR BILL
WOULD ACCOMPLISH AND THEN
WORKING I WHAT WOULD LIKE TO GO
DOWN THE AMENDMENTS OF THE LIST
OF AMENDMENTS -- FOR THE
BENEFITS OF THE PUBLIC AND THE
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND AND THEN WE CAN DISCUSS KIND
OF WHERE WE HAVE OUR OUR
DISAGREEMENT.
AND SEE HOW WE CAN WORK IT OUT --
AT A LATER DATE NOT ARE TODAY
BUT THE IDEA IS TO COME TO A
CONSENSUS.
AND I THINK WE CAN WE'RE NOT FAR
AWAY -- BUT IF YOU COULD JUST
BEGIN SURE ABSOLUTELY MR IN
THANK YOU AND ALL.
MAKE BRIEF OPENING REMARKS AND
THEN -- I HAVE A LIST OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE LARGELY AGREE
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT I I AGREE WITH YOU WILL I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE.
I APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
FLEXIBILITY I WANT TO THANK THE
OUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
VERY CLOSE WITH MY STAFF ON THIS.
ISSUE -- SO OUR COLLEAGUES ON SB
TWO EIGHTY A IS A BI PARTISAN
CLEAN ENERGY BILL -- THAT I'M
PROUD TO BE DOING AUTHORING WITH
SENATOR NIELSEN.
WHAT ONE THING WE SHOW OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HERE IN THE CAPITAL
IS UNLIKE OUR -- COUSINS -- IN
WASHINGTON DC THAT ARE WE CAN
WORK IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER.
NOT EVERY ISSUE IS A PARTISAN
ISSUE SO I WANT TO THANK US
CENTER NIELSEN FOR PARTNERING
WITH US IN THIS BILL -- THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ENABLE --
HOUSEHOLDS ARE BUSINESSES
SCHOOLS AND OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO INSTALL --
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
SUCH AS SOLAR AND STORAGE.
IN ORDER TO SAVE MONEY REDUCE
EMISSIONS -- AND RETAIN POWER IN
TIMES OF EMERGENCY -- OVER ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS
HAVE ALREADY CHOSEN -- TO OBTAIN
THEIR POWER FROM ON SITE
GENERATION AND STORAGE.
OF A FAR MORE WILL BE NEEDED IF
WE'RE TO MEET OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS AND ALSO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
WITH THE TRANSMISSION SYSTEM AND
WILDFIRES -- WILD BOAR DVRS A
DISTRIBUTOR RESOURCES CAN SAVE
CUSTOMERS -- BOTH BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES MONEY.
AND HELP KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
THEIR ON GOING CHALLENGES THE
PREVENT GREATER DEPLOYMENT OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
IN PARTICULAR -- SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT ADDRESSES THE ISSUES OF TO
LEAD INTERCONNECTION --
SOMETIMES SEVERE DELAYS -- AN
OUTDATED TERRACE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT DISTRIBUTED
RESOURCES ARE ON A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD WITH OTHER ALTERNATIVES.
WHEN A SOLAR STORAGE SYSTEM IS
INSTALLED THE LOCAL UTILITY OF
COURSE HAS TO CONNECTED TO THE
GRID?
UNFORTUNATELY AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY THE CASE AT THE
COMMERCIAL LEVEL SO FOR
BUSINESSES OR FOR SCHOOLS --
THESE INTERCONNECTIONS CAN BE
DELAYED MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS
COSTING THE CUSTOMER SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND WASTED TIME.
SB -- TWO EIGHTY EIGHT DIRECTS
THE CPUC AND PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES TO STREAMLINE THE
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS -- THE
BILL IS NOT TAKEN OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE APPROACH IT SIMPLY
DIRECTS THE AGENCIES TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS.
A SIMILAR OUTDATED TERRACE CAN
MEAN THAT DISTRIBUTOR RESOURCES
ARE ON AN EQUAL FOOTING COMPARED
TO OTHER SOURCES OF ELECTRICITY
WITH REGARD TO COMPENSATION FOR
PROVIDING THAT ENERGY INTO THE
GRID. FOR EXAMPLE NO UTILITY IN
THE STATE EITHER PUBLIC OR
INVESTOR OWNED CURRENTLY HAS A
TERROR FOR RAM TO COMPENSATE
STANDALONE STORAGE IN OTHER
WORDS STORAGE WITHOUT SOLAR.
OFFERED FOR DISCHARGING TO THE
GRID DURING TIMES OF PEAK LOAD.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY FIRING UP THE
DIRTY A SPEAKER PLANS TO MEET
DEMANDS.
OF THESE PROTECT THE POTENTIAL
THESE RESOURCES NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED.
A DISTRIBUTOR RESOURCES BENEFIT
ALL CUSTOMERS NOT JUST THE
OWNERS.
BY CLEANING THE AIR AND DURING
THAT ENSURING THE JOB STATE
LOCAL AND PROVIDING ELECTRICITY
DURING EMERGENCIES.
WELL IT TO THE LIST YES AS WELL
AS REDUCING THE NEED FOR COSTLY
UPGRADES -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND IN TERMS OF
THE AMENDMENTS -- I HAVE A LIST
OF IT'S ESSENTIALLY HE'D
AMENDMENTS -- NUMBER -- ONE
WHICHMAKES ODD SEVEN DIFFERENT
CHANGES TO INTENT LANGUAGE
INCLUDING STRIKING THE MENTION
OF THE WORD.
RIGHT FROM THE BILL WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT ON THAT.
A NUMBER -- TWO EXEMPTING
FIFTEEN SMALL PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES WITH COMBINED --
CUSTOMERS HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS STRIKING UP IN THE
BILL WE AGREE TO THAT.
NUMBER THREE ARE REMOVING -- SEE
YOU SEE OVERSIGHT OF P. O. U.
INTERCONNECTION PROCESS -- AND
CHANGING -- BIRTH RESPECT TO THE
CDC REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
PO YOU INTERCONNECTION DELAYS
FROM EVALUATING TO REPORTING --
WE ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT NUMBER
FOR ADDING LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
UTILITIES TO PRIORITIZE CERTAIN
INTERCONNECTION PROJECTS OVER
OTHERS.
WE AGREE TO THAT.
NUMBER -- FIVE MAKE ARE MAKING
STORAGE EXPORT TERROR OF
DEVELOPMENT OPTIONAL AND ADDING
IN GHG LANGUAGE.
SO WE AGREED TO THAT.
AND AND RETALIATION REPAIR
LANGUAGE TO YES IN INDIA HERE.
AND THEN.
THERE'S THAT THOSE OF THE FIVE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO AND THEN THE
THE SIX THAT WE AGREE TO IS.
STRIKING THE SECTION THAT
DIRECTS THE CPC AND K. SO --
DIRECT THEM TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO STORAGE WE
AGREE TO THAT AMENDMENT.
AND THEN THERE TO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS ONE OF THEM IS -- THE
THE COST SHIFTING PROTECTION
LANGUAGE ON ALL STORAGE TERRACE --
WE BELIEVE THAT WERE EXTREMELY
CLOSE TO A RESOLUTION ON THAT --
AND I KNOW MY STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WORKING
TOGETHER ON REMAIN.
ON THAT -- AND SO THAT WE'RE NOT
A 100% OF THE WAY THERE YET BUT
I'M I THINK WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
AND THEN THE FINALLY THE ONE
WHERE WE I THINK JUST WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE DISCUSSIONS IS.
ARE THE BILL -- PROHIBITS A
DISCRIMINATORY INTERCONNECTION
FEES.
AND I THINK THERE'S JUST MORE
DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS TO BE HAD
BETWEEN -- MY OFFICE AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT ISSUE OR NOT
SO WERE WERE NOT YET AN
AGREEMENT ON THE COST OF
PROTECTION BUT I'M CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL GET THERE AND I
THINK WE'RE CLOSE.
AND THEN WE ARE NOT IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE DISCRIMINATORY FEET OF
THE AMENDMENT TO THE
DISCRIMINATORY FEES.
PROVISION IN OUR BILL AND BUT WE
COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
KAMALA VERY EVERYBODY BELIEVES
SO SHOULD BE NO COST SHIPS AND
EVERYBODY ARGUES THERE'S NO
SCHOLARSHIPS AND NOW WE JUST
WANT TO ESTABLISH THAT IN AND
AND SATCHER.
YEAH OKAY VERY WELL.
AND SO -- AND WHAT ELSE I'VE I
BELIEVE THAT WAS.
AND THEN THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL LANGUAGES THAT WERE
MENTIONED AT LANGUAGE CONCERNING
THE RECOGNITION OF THE ARTS TO
PERFORM A CERTIFIED.
STATE IN WHEN INSTALLED TWO
O'CLOCK.
LOOK WILL CODES OR DIDN'T SEEM
TO BE ANY [inaudible]
AND AND THE ONE THAT WE HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT ON IS THIS ONE
RIGHT RIGHT HERE.
THAT ONE IS THE THE TERRACE FOR
ME -- FIFTY MM AND UNDER ON
PAGES SEVEN IN A GROUP WITH
REGARD TO CORTES COMMENTARY FEES --
IT'S UP TO THE TOP OF PAGE AIDS --
I'M AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO TRY TO
REACH RESOLUTION ON THAT BY THIS
POINT WE'RE NOT IN FULL
AGREEMENT.
AND IT CLARIFIES THE UTILITIES
ABILITY CHARGE FEES THAT ARE
JUSTIFIED.
THE DISCRIMINATORY PIECE WE
AGREE WITH THAT.
THERE WERE STILL AT WORK ON THE
HOUR OR SO WORKING ON THAT WERE
NOT IN AGREEMENT YEAH.
AND THE LANGUAGE REQUIRING
TERRACE -- THAT ARE MODIFIED
SHOULD INSTEAD.
ASSESS WHETHER TO MODIFY THE
EXISTING TERRACE.
YEAH THAT'S OKAY OKAY.
THIS ONE'S OKAY.
TO OKAY VERY WELL -- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF IT WE DO HAVE BOND --
TWO WITNESSES ARE TODAY -- TO
GET AROUND TO WITNESSES TO MAKE
COMMON YES BRIEF COMMENTS ARE
GARY THE ARE -- OF EMPIRE AND
NOT COMPANY.
AND THEN DEVON OLIVER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
OF CORPORATION OKAY.
GO AHEAD.
THE PHRASE.
WE DON'T BY HEART.
YES I THANK YOU -- I'M GARY
TERRA I'M A OF I'M -- WITH MY
FAMILY IN A FARMING OPERATION
AND COLUSA CLOSE COUNTING.
AND WE HAVE -- WE GROW IN
PACKING PROCESS WALNUTS AND SO
WE HAVE SEVERAL FARMING
OPERATIONS DIFFERENT ORDERS FOR
PLACES AND HAVE SEWER PROJECTS
BUT WE ARE ARE ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE WERE CAUGHT
UP IN THIS -- INTERCONNECTION
ISSUE.
WE STARTED IN THE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WITH A
OBJECT TO PUT IN A SOLAR SOLAR.
PLANT -- IT WAS ALMOST AS
SEPARATE HER THOUSAND DOLLAR
PROJECT.
HOW WE START IN THE SPRING OF?
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE STILL
DON'T HAVE -- HOOK UPS IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE AT WE DISPOSED TO
HAVE PTO IN AND SET UP BY THE
END OF THE YEAR WHICH WAS GONNA
BE YOU KNOW AROUND DECEMBER OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN HERE WE ARE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE'RE STILL.
IN LIMBO AND DON'T HAVE THE HOOK
UPS AND HAD COUNTLESS MEETINGS
AND CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN HERE
BEFORE WITH THE NOT HERE BUT
HERE AT THE AT THE AT THE
CAPITOL BEFORE WITH OTHER
MEETINGS WITH THE JUST NOT
GETTING ANYWHERE IN SIGHT THAT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
JUST. FOR THE FOR THAT PURPOSE
TO TRY TO GET.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST DEFINITIVE
ANSWERS AND WE'VE WE HAD WE
KNOWN THIS PRIOR -- TO
INITIATING THE PROJECT OF HOW
LONG IT WAS GOING TO BE THE
INTERCONNECTION CHALLENGES WE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE DONE THE
PROJECT AND SO IT'S IT'S IT'S
VERY DAMAGING TO US AND OTHERS
LIKE US.
SO WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH AND TWELVE
MORE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
DEVIN OLIVER AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
THE PARTNERSHIP WAS CREATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
LEADERSHIP ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE AND POLICY.
AND ALSO THOSE WHO BUILD IT.
THE PRO TEM OF THE SENATE AND
THE SPEAKER APPOINT A BOARD AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR -- AND
WIRED FOR A HOUSING ORGANIZATION
SPEAKING WITH A AS A WITNESS SO
WE BECAME INVOLVED IN CLEAN
ENERGY POLICY AND PROGRAMS
ALMOST A DECADE AGO AFTER WE
REALIZED THAT LOW INCOME RENTERS
ALSO HAVE A HUGE STAKE IN THIS
POLICY AREA.
IN A LOT OF WAYS CLEAN ENERGY IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAME IN A
POINT WITH OUR WORK.
NOT BY HELPING LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ACCESS AND BENEFIT
FROM CLEAN ENERGY.
THAT ACTUALLY HELPS US ACHIEVE
OUR GOAL ONE OF OUR GOALS OF
PRESERVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE STATE.
LARGER SAVINGS ON TENANTS ENERGY
BILLS AS WELL AS OWNERS
OPERATING COSTS.
SPECIFICALLY WORK WITH NONPROFIT
PROPERTY OWNERS TO BRING THE
BENEFITS OF SOLAR TO LOW INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS MANY THROUGH
TO KEEP PROGRAM SO IT'S THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
AND THEN THE SO SO OUR MULTI
FAMILY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT'S UPCOMING.
SO AS ADVOCATES FOR ACQUITTAL
ACCESS TO BOTH CLEAN ENERGY AND
ALSO HOUSING WE SUPPORT TO A
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP SUPPORT SB.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT AND THANKS
THANKS TO STATE INVESTMENT IN
SOLAR ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN MULTI
FAMILY FOR A HOUSING.
MORE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
EVER IN THE STATE.
CAN BENEFIT FROM OF TOUGH SOLAR
FOR THEIR ENERGY NEEDS.
REALLY QUICKLY DODD LOPEZ SERVE
THE LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM SERVE.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR NINETY FOUR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH SO
THE PEAVEY AND THE MACHIN SAYS
PROGRAMS ALONE HAVE BROUGHT OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PROJECTS. TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROPERTIES.
OF DESPITE THIS PROGRESS WE HAVE
A LOT OF MORE WORK TO DO AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
THE DISCRIMINATORY FEES OUTDATED
TARIFFS AND ALSO THE RED TAPE
CONTINUE TO THREATEN OUR
PROGRESS IN EXPANDING THE NUMBER
OF LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
BENEFIT FROM CLEAN ENERGY.
JUST LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
INCRIMINATORY FEES
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHO IRONICALLY STAND
TO BENEFIT THE MOST FROM
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION.
AND SO SB TWO EIGHTY IT WOULD
HELP PROTECT LOW INCOME REPAIRS
I'M TAKING ON EVEN GREATER
ENERGY BURDENS THAT DEFINITELY
HIGH AND GETTING HIGHER.
IN BEING FURTHER EXCLUSION FROM
THE CLEAN ENERGY MARKET FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT.
WE'RE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
IDIOT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DID YOU WANT TO
COMMENT SNOW.
OVER SPEAKER SINCE OUR STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M BOB ROEMER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE OF
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO GIVE SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE BUILDING OWNERS
AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND
SUNLAND THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALLEY DO TRADE
WITH AND YOU ARE GLOBAL CLEAN
ENERGY DEVELOPER IN CALIFORNIA
WE DO -- PROJECTS TO SCHOOLS
CITIES COUNTIES AND WATER
AGENCIES ALL OVER THE STATE
WE'VE DONE PROJECTS WITH THE
CITY OF LAKE PORT AND COMPTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
DIE -- DESERT SANDS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL NOT VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SAN
GABRIEL UNIFIED DISTRICT -- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
INTERCONNECTION DELAYS ARE
REALLY COSTLY TO SCHOOLS AND
INHABIT PROHIBIT THEM FROM.
REALIZING THE SAVINGS QUICKER
WHICH THEY USE -- TO REINVEST
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU GREAT ORGANIZATION BY
THE WAY.
MORNING KAREN SHOCKED
REPRESENTING FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THEN I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED BY
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION WHO
COULDN'T GET A REP HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SCOTT
CLINTON I CAME DOWN FROM CLEAR
LAKE -- I AM REPRESENTING
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY THERE
ALSO.
SOLAR USERS THAT COULDN'T MAKE
IT TODAY.
OUR MAIN CONCERN -- IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS THE FACT THAT
MANY OF US HAVE INVEST IN SOLAR
SYSTEMS FOR OUR HOME.
AND OUR CONCERNS ARE THAT WE MAY
HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME RECOVERING
OUR INVESTMENTS BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY SEE.
PROFITS.
AT FROM OUR INVESTMENTS BECAUSE
OF THE POSSIBILITIES OF SURPRISE
TAXES AND OTHER FEES THE COULD
BE LEVIED FROM THE THE UTILITY
COMPANIES THANK YOU SIR SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THE BILL
HEARING YOU VERY MUCH TO ME AND
THANK YOU FOR COMING DOWN.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
WHEN MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON I DO OVER HERE FROM
CENTER FELL ON A CAR?
SELECT PANELS ARE ROOTED GOES
RIGHT IN AND WHAT A PROPER GAS
AND FIVE YEARS.
ON AND I SUPPORT THE BILL.
ON THE AND I WOULD START I'M
SORRY SIR WHAT IS YOUR NAME MY
NAME IS ROBERT MILLS OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- AND I'M RETIRED
CONSUMER CLASS ACTION LAWYER AND
ONE OF THINGS I CAN BRING TO YOU
TODAY YOU KNOW HOW WHAT YOU TO
HOW IMPORTANT WHAT YOU DO IS.
BUT YOU REALIZE HOW REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT IS IF YOU SIT
ACROSS THE TABLE FROM COUNSEL
REPRESENTING -- UTILITY A BANK
OR WHATEVER AND THEY SAY COUNCIL
CAN YOU SHOW ME IN THE LAW
SPECIFICALLY WHERE IT SAYS WE
CAN'T DO THIS TERRIBLE THING
THAT WE'RE DOING.
AND WHAT THE PENALTY IS IF WE DO
DO IT.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE NEED THESE
KINDS OF THINGS -- AND AND YOU
KNOW THE THE THE ODD THAT THIS
THIS BILL IS DIRECTLY
COMPETITIVE.
IT WHAT P. GENIES DOING THANK
AND AND THAT'S THAT'S A FAIR
STATEMENT AND IT'S FAIR FOR THEM --
TO BUT WE NEED OKAY YOUR HELP IN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SPECTRUM ON GOOD MORNING THERESA
BURKE **** ON BEHALF OF CERES
AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN PDF
REPRESENTING THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING AND THE
SCHOOL ENERGY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER IN THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I AM UP.
I'M ROB HOLLY FROM SAN JOSE THIS
IS MY FIRST TIME HERE AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
I INSTALL MY ORIGINAL SOLAR
SYSTEM IN TWO THOUSAND TWO IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I RE
ROOFED AND HAD WHEN STALIN NEW
SYSTEM.
LAST WEEK I HEARD OF THE NEW
FEES THIS MUCH AFFECTED THAT
CORRECTLY IS PROPOSING FOR SOLAR
SYSTEMS.
IF SOLELY UNIQUE PENALIZE LIKE
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR ME
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
WOULD NOT HAVE INSTALLED A NEW
AND LARGER SYSTEM.
THIS HAS TO BE STOPPED BEFORE
THIS SPREADS TO OTHER UTILITIES
LIKE MINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BECOMING.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE FINDER CAM
HERE TINA GALLEY WE'RE HERE FROM
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENT ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BELL I'M
ALSO A CONSTITUENT OF CENTER
NIELSEN THANK.
GOOD MORNING LISA HAGERMAN ON
BEHALF OF D. B. L. PARTNERS A
DOUBLE BOTTOM LINE VENTURE
CAPITAL FIRM BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN PALO ALTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS VANESSA
MONTENEGRO I AM A SOLAR
CONTRACTOR FROM ALAMEDA.
AND I YOU HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE HIGHER FEES.
AND THE ON THEIR VALUE OF THE
SOLAR ENERGY I DON'T THINK THEY
ENERGY.
FROM SOLAR IS BEING VALUE AND
THE INVESTMENT THAT THE PEOPLE.
THIS SELLER CUSTOMERS ARE
PUTTING -- NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT I THINK THIS BILL
DOES A LOT THANK GOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY MARRIAGE PRESENT FOUNDER OF
ACR SOLAR IN -- CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA AND I'M AND VERY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT TO HELP PREVENT AGAINST A
LARGE FEES LIKE SMUD IS ARE
PROPOSING THAT HAVE DONE GREAT
DAMAGE TO MY COMPANY AND JOBS IN
THE AREA BECAUSE OF THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT THEY'VE CREATED
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIKA DAHLE
REPRESENTING DEVON SOLAR ONE OF
THE LARGEST RESIDENTIAL SOLAR
INSTALLERS -- IN THE U. S.
CALIFORNIA'S OUR LARGEST MARKET
MORE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
MY NAME IS DEAN LOWER IN FROM
BROWN'S VALLEY CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT MYSELF AND MY
NEIGHBORS WHO HAVE SOLAR -- MY
HUSBAND AND I ARE SEMI RETIRED
WE HAVE A BUSINESS.
WE DEPEND ON SOLAR BUT WE ALSO
INSTALL THAT SOLAR.
TO SAVE MONEY IN OUR RETIREMENT
YEARS AND MAINTAIN STABLE COSTS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S JOHN SUMMING CINEMA
FAN FOUNDER MANAGING PARTNER OF
PEAK DEMAND OR AN EXECUTIVE
SEARCH CONSULTING FIRM THE WORKS
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
ARE THESE ISSUES -- IMPACT ALL
THE COMPANIES WE WORK WITH AS
WELL AS CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT THIS I CAN'T.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BILL
ABILITY -- FROM VALLEJO.
AND I INSTALLED SOLAR LAST YEAR --
DEFINITELY EXPERIENCED --
PROBLEMS THAT -- THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MORNING MY NAME'S MARIN
FRANCESCHI WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA HEARING VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
GOOD MORNING THE NET MANTEGNA'S
UC SAN DIEGO COP CALPERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ONLY A BURNLEY ON
BEHALF OF TESLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS -- MY NAME
IS ANDY RUSSELL I AM A LOCAL
SELLER IN STOLEN IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. NINETY TEN
WITH BEST TECH SOLAR IN STOCKS
PORT.
I AM GARY GERBER AND FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF SUNLIGHT AND POWER
IN BERKELEY.
WE ARE A SOLAR INSTALLER FOR FOR
THE LAST FORTY TWO YEARS.
I REPRESENT SEVENTY POINT OWNER
EMPLOYEES OF MY COMPANY.
I'M I'M ALSO RELEASE A KID A
CUSTOMER SOLAR AND HAVE BEEN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR IN MY
OWN HOME.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE
EFFECT THAT THE RATES THE BEEN
ERODING HAVE HAD ON ME I WAS A
NET ZERO COST.
SOLAR.
HOUSEHOLD I'M NOW PAYING A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
UTILITY BILLS WHEN I PAID ZERO
ONLY BASICALLY DUE TO CHANGES IN
RATES AND AND FEES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPOSED BY THE UTILITIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEANINE COTTER MY
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR WIENER
THANKS FOR HEARING US OUT TODAY.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I'VE BEEN.
I OWN A SOLAR DESIGN BUILD FIRM
AND I'M A SOLAR CUSTOMER IN
ADVANCE ENERGY STORAGE CUSTOMER
MYSELF AND I'VE SEEN OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
THE VALUE OF SOLAR BEING A ROAD
WHILE CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
HAVE.
BE PART OF FROM BE IMPACTED BY A
SINCE SEVERE CLIMATE CRISIS
THANK YOU.
SURE BECAUSE JUST THE OTHER
QUICK QUESTION GOV BECHARD AWAIT
AND WHICH WERE ABOUT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE RAISE YOUR HAND
HER GOING TO SPEAK?
ALL OF YOU ARE COMING UP TO THE
MIKE OKAY WORK WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS BECAUSE WE WERE GONNA LOSE
A MEMBER.
AND VERY POOR AND I GET HIS
QUESTIONS ON THE RECORD HERE SO
WE'RE GONNA SUSPEND THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
BRIEFLY JUST FOR MINUTE --
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
SYSTEM TO MISTER WINNER ON YOU
KNOW I I JUST WANT TO SHARE YOUR
LIFE STARTED MY FIRST SOLAR
COMPANY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
MY SECOND SOLAR COMPANY IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE IN MY THIRD
SOLAR COMPANY IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX AROUND THE PLANET.
I KNOW THE SPACE PRETTY WELL MY-QUESTION IS WHY DOES THIS
MEASURE APPEAR UNLESS I HAVE IT
WRONG ONLY REQUIRING OF PUBLICLY.
PUBLICLY AREN'T MISTER BLOWN
UTILITIES.
AND INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE'S EVIDENCE
THAT CCA'S ARE OUT THERE AND
THEY'RE NOT ACCEPTING THAT
METERING CONTRACTS IN ENTITIES
WHERE WE'RE EXPANDING THAT WHY
CAN'T WE APPLY THESE THESE
RIGHTS TO EDGE TO TO
JURISDICTIONS.
THAT APPLY TO C. C. A.'S SO THAT
EVERYBODY IS TREATED EQUALLY --
BECAUSE I I'VE HAD EVIDENCE THAT
WEATHER SITUATIONS WITH ARE
LITERALLY NOT ACCEPTING THESE
ARE OBVIOUSLY MORE EXPENSIVE
CONTRACT WHY CAN'T WE MAKE IT
APPLY TO THEM.
NOT THAT I'M HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU I CENTER I
HAVE BEEN THERE OF ACTUALLY IN
THE LAST I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
CCA'S.
WHEN I LOOK AT I'VE HAD OTHER
I'VE HAD OTHER LEGISLATION WHERE
THE CCA'S HAVE ASKED ME POOR
EXEMPTIONS AND I SAID NO?
AND SO I DON'T THIS NO NO I
UNDERSTAND I'M JUST CENTERS MY
GENERAL PHILOSOPHY AYE AYE I
DON'T THINK -- I BUT NOT
SPECIFIC ISSUE -- WHY DON'T WE
COME AND TALK ABOUT THAT I DON'T
WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL UNLESS
I KNOW THAT CCA'S ARE GOING TO
BE INCLUDED I SEE THE NUMBERS
LIKE 40% HUGE NUMBERS?
VESCO TOLD THESE ARE SHRINKING
GENERATION CCA'S ARE GOOD FOR
GOOD REASON A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
ARE DOING ARE GROWING WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
COSTS AND THESE ARE THE THE
BOARD.
THE WITH THE GERMAN WAS SAYING
WITH RESPECT CARSHARING THAT
EVERYBODY HAS THAT AND HERE YOU
HAVE A NEW ENTERPRISES STARTED
TO CURL MAKE CHEN YOUR WHEN YOUR
PREDECESSORS IN THIS PLACE.
AND IT'S GOING GREAT BEAUTIFUL
JUST SHARE THE BURDEN OFFER THE
SAME BILL OF RIGHTS FOR ANYBODY
USES A CUSTOMER AND I I SHOULD I
SHOULD WE WE ACTUALLY OF
DREDGING MY MEMORY HERE WE WE
ARE LOOKING AT THAT EXACT ISSUE.
AND SO -- WE HAVEN'T RULED OUT
DOING THAT.
OKAY YEAH I AYE ROBBINS
CONVERSATION ON THE FLY HERE A
LITTLE BIT BUT I KNOW I KNOW I
APOLOGIZE YOU KNOW I NINE WHY
I'M NOT BOUNCE IN THIS ON SO
SORRY I'M NOT.
I'M NOT IN ANY WAY RULING THAT
OUT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT.
THANKS TO YOU.
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT DID YOU HAVE A
HAVE A QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE IT I HAVE NOT A CLUE.
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD SENATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR TRAVER REALLY
REALLY QUICK QUESTION.
I A I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR ALSO
BROUGHT IT UP AS WELL REGARDING
THE COST SHIFT ISSUE AND I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND
HOW IT RELATES TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT YOU ARE WILLING TO
TAKE OF THE AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE AREN'T GOING.
WITH CAUTION WE ARE -- WE ARE.
WILLING TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT ON
CALL SHARON WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING OUT THE EXACT LANGUAGE
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON IT -- SO
YES WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT ON COST SHARING BUT
WE'RE WE'RE NOT A 100% OF THE
WAY THERE IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
EXACT LANGUAGE WILL BE BUT I
CONSTANTLY WONDER WHAT HE
ACCEPTED PRETTY MUCH ALL THE
AMENDMENTS EXCEPT THAT ONE AND
THAT ONE IS A VERY.
IMPORTANT ONE RIGHT AND BUT THE
DEVIL'S ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS ON
REST ISSUE AND IT'S BEEN THE
GENERAL POLICY OF THE STATE NOT
TO ALLOW COST SHIFT AND AND KLAY
WE DON'T WANT TO PUSH FORWARD
BUILD IS GOING TO DO THAT BUT
AGAIN -- THE LANGUAGE IS VERY
DELICATE ON THAT AND I AND I
HAVE ALWAYS HAD A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH WAS CENTER
WIENER HE'S A MAN OF HIS WORD I
KNOW THAT WE CAN WORK THIS OUT --
BUT THAT'S UP TO YOU IN TERMS OF
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO HI I THINK
WE CAN WORK THIS OUT AND MY AT
MY AGE.
MY MY COMMITMENT IS TO WORK THIS
OUT WITH THE WITH THE OFFICE
BECAUSE STATES AND THE FEELING
IS MUTUAL WE ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND THERE WILL BE A COST SHIFT
AMENDMENT.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF GETTING TO
THE EXACT LANGUAGE ONE IF I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND I WILL BE.
HAPPY TO VOTE THIS BILL OUT
TODAY AND OBVIOUSLY RESERVE MY
RIGHT -- TO CHANGE MY MIND.
THANK YOU CAN I NEARLY AS ON A
REGULAR THAT YOU WANTED.
US HOLDEN OKAY SELF THAT DEBT.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT
WOULD QUALIFY AS THE THE SMALL
BUSINESS I KNOW YOU SAID THAT
THERE'S AN EXEMPTION FOR FIFTEEN
CAN YOU TELL ME.
I KNOW YOU SAID IN A APOLOGIZE.
THERE WAS ON THE EXEMPTION IS --
FOR THE SMALL.
THERE IS A SET OF FIFTEEN SMALL
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES -- AND
COMBINED THEY HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IS A
REALLY MICRO -- PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES THEY'LL BE EXEMPTED
OUT OF THE BILL -- BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO SMALL.
ALRIGHT AND AT YOU KNOW.
NO SECRET TO YOU BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION EARLIER
TODAY AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF CHANGES THAT ARE COMING
OUR WAY.
WHAT I WOULD DEEM SORT OF LAST
MINUTE AND I AND I DO APPRECIATE --
SENATOR WESSEL STATING THAT HIS
SUPPORT FOR YOUR BILL BUT I WANT
TO PUT IT ON RECORD TO I HAVE TO
COST SHIFTING.
AS A CONCERN AS WELL AS THE
DISCRIMINATORY PIECE WHICH I
BELIEVE HE SAID YOU'RE WORKING
ON CORRECT AND AS WELL AS MR
HERTZBERG THE CCA'S I FEEL BAD
ABOUT IT THERE THE GETTING
LARGER AND LARGER AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
EVERYONE.
ONLY SO I HEAR THAT YOU'RE
WILLING.
TO WORK ON ALL THIS BUT I STILL
AS SENATOR WESSEL SAID.
YOU'RE NOT THERE WITH THE COST.
FIFTEEN THE TRACTION SO I'M YOU
KNOW TO HAVE CONCERNS I JUST
WANT TO PAY FOR THE RECORD AND
AND THANK YOU FOR TRYING TO AND
THAT IT MAKES I JUST.
JUST.
TO US I I'M AWARE THAT IT MAKES
SIX MEMBERS THAT ARE.
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT ISSUE TO
SO YEAH AND WERE WERE AND WE
WILL KEEP YOU UPDATED ON OUR
PROGRESS ON IT AS WELL AND WE
SHOULD YEAH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO THE
PUBLIC SER WRSE WERE HEARING
FROM SUPPORTERS THANK YOU SORRY
FOR FOR THIS INTERRUPTION.
YOU'RE VERY IMPORTANT TO US HI
MY NAME IS STEVE BROYLES -- LIVE
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I WORK IN
BERKELEY FOR SUNLIGHT IN POWER.
I'M IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU.
MARTIN FELT ON LICENSE.
CALIFORNIA LICENSE SOLAR
CONTRACTOR FIFTEEN YEARS --
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR Và.
BEGINNING ADVANCED ENERGY I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
BILL SB.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS TWENTY HUNTER ON BEHALF
OF THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS STAN RESTAURANT
WITH GOOD ALTERNATIVES I ALSO
REPRESENT THE SB THREE FIFTY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ADVISOR GROUP WHICH IS APPOINTED
BY THE P. C. ON THE C. E. C..
ADVISE THEM ON PROGRAM FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'M AS
WE ALL KNOW DISADVANTAGE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES FACE THE
HIGHEST BARRIERS TO ADOPTING AND
PARTICIPATING IN A CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAMS.
AND ALSO HAVE THE LEAST CAPACITY
TO RECOVER AND RESPOND TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IMPACTS SO I SEWER AND STORAGE --
PROVIDE SOME GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR RESILIENCY AT THE HOUSEHOLD
LEVEL.
BUT THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HI EVERYBODY.
I'M GRAY SEEKS AND I GOT FREE
SOLAR AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU.
THAT I'M SO APPRECIATIVE THAT
THEY THAT I WAS ABLE TO GET IT.
IT DUMB.
THE IT REALLY HELPED ME IN MY
LIFE BECAUSE I LIVE ON SOCIAL
SECURITY ONLY AND IT MAKES A LOT
OF DIFFERENCE FOR ME THE WAY I
LIVE.
AND I WANT ONE IS SAFE FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AND 'VE LIVED HERE ALL MY LIFE
SO I KNOW WILL ALWAYS BE IN NOW
I I FEEL SO DIFFERENT HAVING
SOLAR ON MY RULE.
I I FEEL LIKE I LIVE IN
HOLLYWOOD.
THANK YOU NATALIE THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
SHARE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS -- HI
BECKER WRESTLE WITH GOOD
ALTERNATIVES NORTH VALLEY AND
I'M IN SUPPORT.
I ERICA STRIKER WITH CAPITAL
CITY SOLAR I AM A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER OF AND MY FULLER COMPANY
FOR NINETEEN YEARS I'VE
THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS AND I I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S DAVE SCHWEIKER
JUNIOR -- I SUPPORT BUILD.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS PAT PANDERING I
REPRESENT THE SUNLIGHT.
SUNRISE MOVEMENT I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THIS
IS MY FIRST VISIT TO THE CAPITAL
AND I TOOK THE AMTRAK TRAINS
SPOKESMAN THIS MORNING TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL.
I THINK HE'S THAT THIS
DISCRIMINATED CONSOLE USERS
WOULD BE A BARRIER TO REACHING A
100% RENEWAL OF ENERGY.
LAWMAKERS SHOULD STAND UP IN
SOLITARY WITH CONSUMERS NOT WITH
UTILITIES LOBBYING YES THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK.
HI I'M DANOS WARM PRESENCE
SPECTRUM ENERGY DEVELOPMENT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE ABOUT
FORTY SEVEN EMPLOYEES STATEWIDE
DOING SOLAR.
IN AGRICULTURE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUSINESSES OF ALL SORTS -- I'D
LIKE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK THE CO AUTHORS
FOR US.
OF WE'RE SEEING TODAY I USED TO
RUN THE SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT SOLAR PROGRAM
BACK IN THE DAY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE UTILITY
THAT WAS THE POSTER CHILD.
FOR GOOD SOLID SOLD FRIENDLY
POLICIES AND DEVELOPING SOLAR
NOW -- TRYING TO IMPOSE
DISCRIMINATORY BEHIND THE METER
FEES.
THAT WOULD SLASH THE VALUE OF
SOLAR TO ITS CUSTOMERS THANK GOD
WE'VE HAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MARCUS SMITH --
DRAWING FROM NAPA CALIFORNIA
THIS MORNING STRONG SUPPORT
SENATE BILL.
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT OUR SUPPORT THE
BILL FOR MULTIPLE REASONS ONE
BEING THE PROHIBITION AGAINST
FEES TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
SOLELY USERS.
AND I'M A BIG ADVOCATE OF A
SOLAR IN ACCESS THESE AFFORDABLE
SOLAR AND ACCESS FOR ALL INCOME
BRACKETS THANK YOU SIR THANKS
FOR COMING.
MY NAME IS DAVID ROSENFELD WITH
THE SOLAR RIGHTS ALLIANCE WHERE
AN ASSOCIATION OF RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS RENTERS
BUSINESSES FARMERS AND HAVE
SOLAR IN ALSO SOLAR SUPPORTERS
WE BELIEVE.
THAT EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO
MAKE AND STORE THROWN ENERGY
FROM THE SUN WITHOUT
UNREASONABLE INTERFERENCE IN RED
TAPE AND BARRIERS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SEAMUS
BRENNAN I'M A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT TO HELP THE CITIZEN.
TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN THEIR
FUTURE ENERGY NEEDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NOR NIELSEN CEO SHE COLLECTOR
ECHO A SIXTY YEAR OLD COMPANY
THAT HAS EIGHTY EMPLOYEES -- AND
ALSO -- COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
OWNERS STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
RICK BROWN TEAR VERY ENERGY --
I'M ALSO HERE I'M AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE SCHOOL ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- WE'VE HELPED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PUBLIC AGENCIES
INCLUDING SCHOOLS AROUND THE
STATE IMPLEMENTS ALL OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
AND THEY'RE NOW SAVING EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS YEAR I WANT TO
COMMENT QUICKLY ON THE COST
SHIFT ISSUE WE ARE WE ARE DOING
RESEARCH FUNDED BY THE NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGYCOMMISSION.
ON THIS ISSUE AND I HAVE TO SAY
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF MESS
AROUND WITH THE KASHIF IS AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH CCA'S WITH
THE RESEARCH ENTITIES. TO SHOW
HOW BEHIND THE METER SOLAR
ACTUALLY PROVIDES BENEFITS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY CALCULATED IN THE
COST SHIFT ISSUES SO IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT I'M
GLAD TO RESPOND TO THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BERNADETTE DEL
KERO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS IT WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
LONGSTANDING INVESTMENT IN SMALL
BUSINESSES WE HAVE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS. 70% OF WHICH
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES SUPPORTING
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND JOBS THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT MERE DRIVER.
RICK WALTER CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTOR AND MY COUNTLESS.
CLIENTS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR HAVE NO VOICE AGAINST THE
FEES THAT ARE BEING IMPOSED.
TO DISCRIMINATORY FEES BY THE
UTILITIES A BILL LIKE THIS IS
THE ONLY VOICE THEY'LL HAVE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TRAVIS HALL I'VE BEEN
IN -- SOLAR SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN I REPRESENTS ON STORE
SOLAR WE SPECIALIZE I OBVIOUSLY
SOLAR AND STORAGE.
AND THE NUMBER ONE REASON WHY
PEOPLE GO SOLAR SAVE MONEY THE
WAY THEY OBTAIN THAT IS CONTROL.
SOLAR ALLOWS US TO CONTROL OUR
RATE.
AND WHAT WE PAY FOR OUR ENERGY
IN THIS BILL NOT PASSING IT WILL
TAKE THAT IT THAT CONTROL AWAY
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS THANK SO
WE BRIDGEPORT.
WITH US ALL THIS THE FARMS.
AT A STANISLAUS COUNTY WE ALSO
FORMAT OF OR BUILD A STRONG
SUPPORT AND I'M ALSO PROUD THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ALMOND ALLIANCE --
SUPPORTS THIS AND I HOPE YOU'LL
LOVE HAVE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BONNIE FONDRE CAM
HOMEOWNER AND A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
THE STATE WITH.
THE HIGHEST PER CAPITA SUNSHINE
AND LAND IN THE UNION ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO UTILIZE THAT
WONDERFUL RESOURCE WE HAVE SOLAR
WE SHOULD BE DOING.
THANK YOU.
I ALEX MARS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY STORAGE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI TODD FOR HAD IN BEHALF OF
SOME STREET ENERGY GROUP AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE MORNING MY NAME'S AWESOME
WRITER AND I'M STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING GABOR LINE FOR US
FROM CALL CALIFORNIA AND I
APPLAUD YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TO TAKE US TO SB ONE
HUNDRED CONCLUSION.
AND I THINK THIS BILL TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PROVIDES GUARD RAILS TO
GET US THERE THANK YOU.
VIRGIN AYE VOTE.
MORNING MY NAME IS RANDY SOBRE.
A MOTOR -- I SUPPORT THE SP. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT FOR MY INVESTMENT.
AND DON'T LIKE TO SEE IT GO
BACKWARDS IN BE ATTACKED SO.
I'D LIKE.
TO AND I VOTE PLEASE.
CHRIS REYES ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK. TO HAVE -- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
MIGHT.
THROW MYSELF AT THE END OF THE
LINE.
I I'M I WAS AT THE TABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS NOT
JUST.
GIVE US YOUR NAME SUCH
CONSTANTINE VOTE SOLAR
REGULATORY DIRECTOR VOTE SOLAR
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS BILL FOR MANY REASONS AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT IF NECESSARY.
UP US BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION IF
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM APPEAR ON
THE ON THE TABLE PLEASE.
YEAH ONLY WITH THE BECAUSE THEY
WERE THERE YEAH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
BEGINNING WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
MATT FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK -- WERE
HERE EIGHT TO OPPOSE SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT TODAY I'M WEDO
SUPPORT THE INCREASED RELIANCE
ON ENERGY STORAGE AND WE THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
STATE'S RESOURCE PLANNING
OBJECTIVES -- AND WE SUPPORT
REMOVING UNFAIR BARRIERS TO
TIMELY INTERCONNECTION.
BUT WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TYING
THE HANDS OF STATE REGULATORS TO
FAIRLY ASSIGNED COSTS ACROSS ALL
GROUPS OF CUSTOMERS.
ON WE KNOW THAT SOME AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TODAY WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THE AMENDMENTS IN PRINT.
BEFORE WE CHANGE OUR POSITION --
BUT OUR CONCERNS ARE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THE LANGUAGE THAT
IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT COULD
RESULT IN SUBSTANTIAL COST
SHIFTING AND RAISE RATES FOR THE
CUSTOMERS THAT DO NOT OWN
OPERATE OR AT LEAST BEHIND THE
METER DISTRIBUTED ENERGY.
RESOURCES.
THESE CAUTIOUS ARE NOT JUSTIFIED
THERE UNNECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED DEPLOYMENT OF
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES AND
STORAGE SYSTEMS AND THEY WOULD
INCREASE THE AFFORDABILITY
BURDEN FOR MANY LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CUSTOMERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
IN PARTICULAR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS RELATING
TO ONSITE GENERATION AND STORAGE
MAY HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT CANNOT BE FULLY UNDERSTOOD
AT THIS TIME.
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS COULD HAMPER
THE DEVELOPMENT OF FUTURE
TERRORISTS.
IN RULES THAT ATTEMPT TO BALANCE
THE INTERESTS OF VARIOUS
CUSTOMER GROUPS ENSURE GREAT
RELIABILITY AND FAIRLY
APPORTIONED SYSTEM COSTS.
CUSTOMERS THAT DON'T HAVE
STORAGE SYSTEMS DON'T HAVE
SIMILAR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS THAT
PROTECT THEM AGAINST COST
SHIFTING.
AND THAT'S A MAJOR OMISSION SO
IF THIS PROVISION RELATING TO
RIGHTS IS REMOVED FROM THE BILL
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR CONCERN.
WE ALSO STRONGLY OBJECT TO THE
DEPRIVATION THAT WOULD RIGIDLY
CONSTRAIN THE AUTHORITY OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO
DESIGN SENSIBLE TERRACE THAT
BOUNCE THE COSTS AND BENEFITS
PROVIDED BY THESE RESOURCES.
THE BILL AS DRAFTED NOW WOULD
PREVENT THE COMMISSION FROM
ASSIGNING ANY COST
RESPONSIBILITY TO A CUSTOMER FOR
PRODUCTION CM
ENERGY RESOURCE THAT IS CONSUMED
ON SITE.
THIS IS KIND OF A RED FLAG
BECAUSE THE P. C. HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH THE DESIGN OF THESE
TERRORISTS AS PART OF ITS NET
ENERGY METERING PROCESS.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMISSION WILL BE LOOKING AT
THE THIRD REVISION OF THE NET
ENERGY METERING RULES SOMETIME
LATER THIS YEAR THIS BILL COULD
HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT ON THOSE
RULES.
I'M UNLESS OF CUSTOMER IS
PHYSICALLY DISCONNECTED FROM THE
ELECTRIC GRID IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE TO CATEGORICALLY
PROHIBIT ANY COSTS FROM BEING
CHARGED TO THEM FOR A GENERATION
THAT IS NOT EXPORTED.
LOOK THERE A LOT OF COST COMING
DOWN RIGHT NOW WHEN UTILITY
RATES THIS THIS COMMITTEE HAS
HEARD ABOUT PLENTY OF THEM --
THERE'D BEEN BILLS APPROVED TO
AUTHORIZE SPENDING ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ON TREE
TRIMMING WE HEARD TODAY.
CERTAINLY WILDFIRE LIABILITIES A
BIG ONE EVERY CUSTOMER WOULD
LIKE TO BE EXEMPT FROM HAVING TO
PAY THEIR SHARE OF THESE COSTS --
BUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT ISSUING SUCH
EXEMPTIONS I'M WHETHER YOU
INSTALL A STORAGE SYSTEM HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH WHETHER
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR WILDFIRE
LIABILITY -- SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BILLS THAT GO
THROUGH HERE.
DON'T CARVE UP THE CUSTOMER BASE
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
ONLY SOME CUSTOMERS WHO REMAIN
TO PAY THE BILL AND FINALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE LANGUAGE
PROTECTING AGAINST COST SHIFTING
WE ARE EAGERLY LOOKING TO SEE
THE LANGUAGE AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH SENATOR WINNERS
OFFICE ON THIS.
BUT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT --
SIMILAR LANGUAGE IN STATE LAW
WAS PRETTY MUCH IGNORED BY THE
P. YOU SEE IN ITS DSIGN OF THE
NET METERING SUCCESSOR TARIFF.
WHERE IT'S SIMPLY CONCLUDED THAT
IT COULDN'T DETERMINE WHETHER
COST SHIFTING WAS OCCURRING EVEN
THOUGH THE MODEL THAT IT WAS
RELYING ON FOUND THAT EVERY
SINGLE PROPOSAL IN THE CASE
INCLUDING THE ONE THAT THEY
ADOPTED?
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL COST SHIFTING
THANK YOU.
ROGER ROGER THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES SOCI ATION
REPRESENTING OVER SIXTY PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
WATER AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
AS HE HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION IN OUR MEMBERS
ARE.
AND NATIONAL LEADERS -- ON
IMPLEMENTING ENERGY PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SAFE AFFORDABLE
RELIABLE AND SUSTAINABLE AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE OF
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION.
AND EVERY YEAR OUR MEMBERS.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE EFFICIENTLY
APPROVED THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMER
INTERCONNECTION REQUESTS AND
INNER FOCUSED ON ENSURING DG IS
APPROPRIATELY INTEGRATED TO THE
LECTERN GRAD.
WE APPRECIATE THE THRONE ALICE'S --
DONE BY THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
AND UNDERSTAND THAT A SERIES OF
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN TODAY
THAT -- WE LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW AND I THINK THE
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF HER CONCERNS
IN PARTICULAR WE'D APPRECIATE.
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT REMOVING CC
OVERSIGHT OF PUBLIC AND ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AS THEIR LOCALLY
GOVERNED -- ELECTRIC UTILITIES.
I'M WERE WELL I'M A LITTLE BIT
UNCLEAR ON EXACTLY WHAT.
USE HAVE BEEN EXEMPT FROM THE
BILL LAST NIGHT WE ARE TOLD TO
BE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
UNDER CUSTOMERS IN TODAY I'M
HERE A DIFFERENT NUMBER SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THAT
AMENDMENT AS WELL.
AND THE REMAINING ISSUES ARE
REALLY THE TARIFF -- FOR STORAGE
ONLY AND THE COST SHIFT ISSUE
I'M SEE MAYES MEMBERS OR ARE
MUST MEET A HOST OF STATUTORY
DIRECTIVES INCLUDING WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION MEETING OUR PS
MAINTAINING THEIR ELECTRIC GRID
TO CERTAIN STANDARDS AND THAT
THAT.
THAT DRIVES THE COSTS AND THE
RATES -- SO WE ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS HAD SUBMITTED LANGUAGE
THAT AUTHORS OFFICE INTO THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE THINK WOULD
RESOLVE THE COST SHIFT
APPROPRIATELY.
AND WOULD ENSURE THAT FEES.
THAT UTILITIES CAN CHARGE FEES
AND TO ENSURE THAT THEIR REVENUE
OBLIGATIONS ARE NOT.
CHANGED OR HINDERED BY -- THEY
CONTINUED INTERCONNECTION OF
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION SO MOVING
FORWARD IN CLOSING.
IF THE BILL MOVES OUT TODAY WITH
FORD COMMUTING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS -- TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR PEER USED
TO MEET THEIR STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS TO PROVIDE SAFE
AFFORDABLE POWER WITHOUT
UNFAIRLY SHIFTING COSTS TO OTHER
CUSTOMERS THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON JAZZ
MONEY JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS.
ASSOCIATION -- WE REPRESENT
WHOLESALE -- RENEWABLE RESOURCES
AS WELL AS STORAGE MY MEMBERS
HAVE DEPLOYED -- SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF RENEWABLE IN THE
STATUS IS COMMITTEES WELL AWARE --
AND WE'VE ALSO DEPLOYED --
STORAGE -- WHERE IN FACT IT IT
WORKS?
WE ARE PROUD OF THAT IS LOW COST
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
ALL CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS WHERE
THEY OWN A HOME OR NOT -- AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE FINANCIAL
WHEREWITHAL -- TO BUY EQUIPMENT --
OR OR NOT -- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TO SUPPORT THAT -- I
PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
PROMOTING SOLAR ENERGY SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SO I DON'T NEED
TO BE CONVINCED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT -- IN MEDIAN --
ALL OF OUR GOALS HOWEVER --
WE'VE OPPOSE THIS BILL PRIMARILY
A SECTION -- FOR OF THE BILL --
WHICH BASICALLY SHIFTS THINGS
SIGNIFICANTLY CUSTOMER CITED --
GENERATION IS STORED SHOULD BE
USED FOR CUSTOMER PURPOSES AT
THE CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
PROGRAMS THAT THAT DO THAT WITH
THIS BILL BASICALLY -- IS
SUGGESTING IS THAT WE MOVE FROM
THAT TO BASICALLY AGGREGATING OR
INDIVIDUALLY HAVING CUSTOMERS
NOW INTERACT WITH THE WHOLESALE
MARKET WHICH IS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT -- MARKET -- AND
SOMETHING TO GETS COMPLICATED
VERY VERY QUICKLY -- AS I THINK
MISTER -- YOU KNOW IT IT WITHIN
THE CUSTOMER SIDE A GUY CONTEXT
PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED TO THE
BENEFITS OF THAT ROUTE THAT
RESOURCE TO THE EXTENT THERE'S
ACCESS SOLAR ENERGY COMING OUT
OF THE NUMBER ROGER EXT.
THEY GET THE ENERGY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE AND THAT'S THE
PROPER WAY TO BE THINKING ABOUT
THIS -- MOVING FORWARD -- THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION --
AS WELL AS YOU GUYS SO I THINK
AS MR FRIEDMAN -- AS INDICATED
ON I'M NOT GOING TO REITERATE
WHAT HE SAID -- BUT ARE BE ARE
BASICALLY ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN A
NUMBER OF PROCEEDINGS TRYING TO
DEAL WITH.
TECH WHAT SO ARE SOME OF THE
REL TECHNICAL CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU ACTUALLY -- YOU KNOW HOW
YOU IN A CONNECTION OF ALL OF
THAT STUFF IS IN PLAY BOTH AT AT
THE AT THIS -- PP YOU SEE AND
THE CAL I SO THE AGGREGATORS WHO
YOU DO NOT HEAR FROM TODAY WHO
ARE COMMERCIALLY TRYING TO
AGGREGATE ALL THE SEXES
GENERATION ARE VERY ACTIVE IN
THOSE PROCEEDINGS.
AND THAT'S FINE -- BUT YOU DOES
IT AGAIN STANDALONE STORAGE IS A
GOOD IDEA IN A FINISH UP IN A
SECOND HERE -- BUT IT BUT AGAIN --
THE IT IS SUBJECT TO THESE OTHER
PROCEEDINGS ONE LAST NOTE.
AND I'M SPEAKING AS A RATE PAYER
I MISS MY CUSTOMER AND I HAPPILY
SIGNED OFF ON MY NEIGHBORS
ROOFTOP SOLAR BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD IDEA.
I DON'T BECAUSE I THINK SMOG IS
A GREAT JOB THAT THE YOU KNOW
SINUS CLEAN ELECTRICITY BUT THEY
DID.
HOWEVER I DID NOT SIGN UP TO
BASICALLY PAY FOR THE COSTS THAT
THERE ARE BAD EATING -- BUT BY
DRIFTING OFF THE SYSTEM AND SO
I'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT
DISCRIMINATED FEES THAT IS NOT
THE POLICY OF **** IT'S
BASICALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY'S LEFT HOLE.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S I THINK
WHAT YOU HEARD FROM MISTER WE
WENT TO A SPEAKING ON THE BEHALF
OF THE I. O. U. CUSTOMERS JUST
SPEAKING AS ONCE MY CUSTOMER AND
I'M SURE TO MANY OF US THAT.
SHARE THAT MY NEIGHBORS ARE YEAH
I'M HAPPY TO DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT IN TERMS OF SIGNING OFF ON
THE SEE SEE AN ARTISTIC INPUT
SELLER ON THE ROUGH.
BUT I DON'T FOOT THE BILL.
JOHN THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIRMAN THERE'S REBEKAH LEE ON
BEHALF OF A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AND I'LL BE BRIEF HERE I
THREE SPECIFIC POINTS
CALIFORNIA'S HAS HAD AN ALPHABET
SOUP OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORT.
THE OUR GROSS LEADING TO THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL DRAMATIC GROWTH
AND D. R. ADOPTION IN OUR
SERVICE AREA WE HAVE
INTERCONNECTED OVER.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
TO THESE TECHNOLOGY TYPES OVER.
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED MAKE A WHAT
AND THE QUESTION THAT WE SPEAK
OF IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
BENEFIT THESE CUSTOMERS PROVIDE
IN OUR COST TO SURF THEM.
RIGHT NOW THAT AT THE WE
ESTIMATE THAT COST TO BE HAVE
EVEN EXCEEDED.
THE SUPPORT WE PROVIDE OUR LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS ON CARE RATES --
WHICH IS NOW USED TO SERVE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION CUSTOMERS MY
SECOND POINT IS THAT.
WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
PURPOSE OF THE INTERCONNECTION
PROCESS WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
IN.
CONNECTING THESE CUSTOMERS WITH
A STREAMLINED APPROACH HOWEVER
IF THE INTERCONNECTION PROCESS
IS SPECIFICALLY TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY OF THE
DISTRIBUTION GRAY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE NON PARTICIPATING
CUSTOMERS AND THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT IN TODAY'S AGE.
IT IF WE ARE TO MAKE SAFETY OUR
PRIORITY MY THIRD POINT IS THAT.
WE HEARD TODAY ON EQUAL RULES
WITH REGARDS TO OTHER SERVICE
PROVIDERS LIKE THE COMMUNITY
CHOICE ACT READERS SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THE
COMMUNITY CHOICE AYE BREEDERS
ARE SUBJECT TO COMPARABLE AND
EQUAL RULES THAT WE HAVE -- HERE
TOO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN NUMBERS
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC I THINK -- I WE
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MISTER FREEDMAN ON THE P. YOU
SEE IGNORE IN SOME OF THE
EXISTING LAWS ON THE NO COST
SHIFTING.
ALSO WE WE EAGERLY AWAIT THE THE
ARRIVAL OF THE AMENDMENTS TO SEE
HOW WHAT THE WORDS LOOK LIKE
BECAUSE THE WORDS REALLY DO
MATTER JUST TO ILLUSTRATE WHAT
KASHIF LOOKS LIKE FOR SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS TODAY.
IT'S AN ANNUAL FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR COST
SHIFT BY COMPARISON THE CARE
PROGRAM WHICH SUPPORTS OUR LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN MILLION SO
IT'S ALMOST FOUR TIMES.
WHAT WE'RE PAYING TO SUPPORT LOW
INCOME CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS ON THE INTERCONNECTION
PEAS LAST YEAR WE INTERCONNECT?
NAM CUSTOMER THAN AN AVERAGE OF
TWO AND HALF DAYS SO IF THERE
ARE ISSUES OUT THERE WE ARE NOT
AWARE OF THEM -- AND JUST TO ADD
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT PIECE FURTHER
WE WERE IN SEPTEMBER WERE GOING
TO COMPLETE A SIX POINT FOUR
MEGAWATT MICHAEL GOOD PROJECT
WITH THE MORE MORE AIR BASE --
IN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY THEY
HAVE ASKED US -- TO PUT TOGETHER
A CASE STUDY TO JUST ILLUSTRATE
HOW WELL THAT INTERCONNECTION
PROCESS HAS GONE SO WE GLADLY
WELCOME OUR CUSTOMERS TO COME
WORK WITH US ON HOW WE CAN MAKE
THAT PROCESS BETTER.
BUT WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY
PROBLEMS IN THAT SPACE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO VIENNA FLEMING'S ON
BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED AND BE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WE BELIEVE THEY ADDRESS
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS HOWEVER
WITH RESPECT TO THE COST SHIFT
LANGUAGE AND THE DISCRIMINATORY.
FEES WE ARE STRONGLY ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE RAISED BY
MISTER FRIEDMAN AT TURN -- WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO SS OBJECT BEES THAT ARE
JUSTIFIED -- WHEN NECESSARY AND
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT -- IN P.
GENIES TERRITORY ALONE IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE KASHIF WORD
NAM NAM FOR NAM CUSTOMER NAM NON
PARTICIPATING CUSTOMERS WAS
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO -- WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS -- THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THE COST
SHIFTING AND THE DISCRIMINATORY
LANGUAGE AND WE THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DELYLAH CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME HAVE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
FORTY WE'RE HERE WITH AND POSE
LESS AMENDED POSITION WE DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THE BILL APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS.
AND LOOKING FOR TECH CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ON THIS THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
POWER THOR'S AGENCY.
AND LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF US CMU
WAY AND CAN LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTAIN TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR DOT.
AND THEN SENATOR BRETT
[inaudible]
SIR BRADFORD.
Q. -- AND I'M GONNA THINK CENTER
WIENER I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES AS IT RELATES.
TO ENTER CONNECTING BUT MY
BIGGEST ISSUE IS ONE THAT WE'VE
HEARD TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
AND THE ISSUE OF COST SHIFT.
AND TO CONTINUE TO ACT AS IF.
LOW INCOME FOLKS BENEFIT FROM
THIS WHEN THEY PAY THE BURDEN OF
THE LAW WITH THE NON SOLAR
CUSTOMERS PAY FOR THIS ROGRAM --
EXERT TELL ME HOW ONE BENEFITS
FROM THE EXCESS POWER THAT'S
LEFT OUT ON THE GRID FROM OVER
GENERATION FROM SOLAR BECAUSE IN
A MODERN.
FLEXIBLE RENEWABLE CLEAN GREAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A VARIETY
OF RESOURCES OUT THERE FROM
UTILITY SCALE -- TO COMMUNITY
SCALE TO INDIVIDUAL SCALE ALL OF
THOSE RESOURCES NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER THE EXCESS ENERGY HOW
DO YOU HOW DOES HOW DOES A
CUSTOMER BENEFIT FROM THE ACCESS.
ELECTRON THAT'S PUT ON THE WATER.
I AM THERE'S NO BENEFIT BECAUSE
THE GREAT IS NOT BI DIRECTIONAL
SO.
WHETHER TO PUBLIC ON UTILITY OR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY THEY
STEAL HAVE PURCHASE FOR THAT
CUSTOMER SO TO CONTINUE TO PAY.
A SOLAR CUSTOMER A RETAIL RATE
FOR A WHOLESALE COMMODITY THAT'S
TOTALLY USELESS IS NO WAY TO
KNOW IN ADVANCE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A ACTUALLY
ELECTRONS ON THE WIRE SO THAT'S
THE STRANDED ASSET OUT THERE.
THAT NO ONE BENEFITS FROM.
SENATE RIGHT THE REAL ISSUE WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED WITH IS TO
DELAY AN INTERCONNECTION BUT TO
SIT HERE AND SAY THAT THERE IS A
BENEFIT FROM A NEW HELP. FOR NON
SOLAR CUSTOMERS FROM A NEON
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S THE BIGGEST
WASTE OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
REPAIR DOLLARS RIGHT TO TODAY.
AND AGAIN FOR US TO SPEND MORE
MONEY REIMBURSING.
SOLAR CUSTOMERS NOW WE DO FOR
CARE CUSTOMERS SHOULD BE IS A
CRIME.
SENATOR FIRST I I DISAGREE WITH
THE PREMISE THT THERE IS NO
BENEFIT TO TO THOSE CUSTOMERS
BUT EVEN AS IT APPLIED
DIRECTIONAL GREG.
THE ELECTION IS IT A BI
DIRECTIONAL ABSOLUTELY ON A
CERTAIN LEVEL THOSE ELECTRONIC
LIKE WELL OUT OF THE HOW YOU
DOING.
ANYTIME THAT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
EXTRA ELECTRONS ON THE GRID SO
THEY STILL HAVE THE BY FOR THAT
CUSTOMER DOWNSTREAM.
IS THIS A QUOTE.
IS CENTER WERE HAPPY TO ANSWER
BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE IF MY
WITH AS GOOD AS YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION RIGHT WHAT I IT'S NOT A
BY DIRECT RICH AND HE DOES NO NO
OKAY SO.
IT WAS A STATEMENT NOT A
QUESTION [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY A CENTER DOT.
YEP SAID THE CENTER RIGHT I
TALKED TO BEFORE I'M GONNA
FOLLOW THE CHAIRS.
LEAD TODAY OUT ON THIS ISSUE BUT
THIS -- THIS ISSUE WITH REGARD
TO THE CCA'S VERY TROUBLING TO
ME AND I WASN'T HERE FOR THAT.
YEAH THE OPPOSITION -- THE
CONVERSATION BUT I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT -- WE NEED TO TREAT
EVERYBODY FAIRLY I HEARD I HEARD
YOU BEFORE I LEFT THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO BE WORKING -- WHAT BY
JUST?
YEAH WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I
RESERVE THE RIGHT ALL AS WELL.
TO CHANGE ON FOR CENTER I
APPRECIATE THAT I DID GO BACK
AND TO MY NOTES TO REMIND MYSELF
THIS IS A ISSUE SO WE AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE BUT IN GENERAL EVEN IF
YOUR CCA COUNTRY.
COUNTRY SEE SEE A CUSTOMER --
YOU IN THE INTERCONNECTION
ISSUES AND THE ISSUES THAT WERE
TALK ABOUT THIS BILL STILL
TYPICALLY RUN THROUGH THE IRISH
YOU.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING YOUR
INTERCONNECTION THROUGH YOUR CCA
IT'S STILL.
THROUGH THE I OWE YOU FOR THE
MOST PART SO THE VISIT OUR SITE
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
THE CCA'S ARE ACTUALLY INVOLVED
IN THESE INTERCONNECTION ISSUES
WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO MORE
DEEPLY AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE PROBLEM WE OP ABSOLUTELY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
PART OF THE SOLUTION AS WELL.
WE DON'T THINK OF THE CCA'S ARE
ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN THESE
ACTIVITIES FOR THE MOST PART
WE'RE GONNA LOOK INTO MORE
DEEPLY AND WE WILL LET YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT WHAT THINK FURTHER
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT -- CCA'S
WANNA DO MICHAEL GRADS IN THOSE
TYPE OF THING SO I THINK AT SOME
POINT IN TIME.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S ONLY GONNA BE A
MATTER TIME WHEN THEY ARE GOING
TO BE.
YEAH YOU WE WILL BE AN ISSUE IT
SEEMS TO ME.
WE WILL LIKE TO RUN A LOT MORE
DEEPLY INTO IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WERE COVERED.
CINEMARK THANK YOU.
WHICH CHURCH JUST LOOKING AT
THIS FROM THE THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL -- TO WORK WORK WE'VE
GOT TO BE CAREFUL UNDERSTAND
TRANSIT ADAPT AND WE WILL GET TO
BE A LITTLE MORE PROACTIVE THAN
REACTIVE AND AYE AYE AYE A
LITTLE BIT A LITTLE FRUSTRATED
WATCHING THE WATER.
UTILITIES WHERE THEY HAVE SAID
TO US WE NEED TO CONSERVE
BECAUSE RUN A DROUGHT.
AND SO WE WE REDUCED OUR USAGE
OF WATER AND THEN THEY REALIZE
THEIR REVENUES.
WHEN?
IT'S ALL OF A SUDDEN THE RATES
WENT UP.
AND SO WE WERE PENALIZED FOR
DOING WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
AND I'M -- IT ARE A LITTLE UPSET
WITH THE WITH THE DYSFUNCTIONAL
ISM OF WHAT GOVERNMENT AND
UTILITIES ARE DOING [inaudible]
TWO CUSTOMERS AND SO I I JUST
WANTED TO KIND OF BRING THAT.
OUT THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE MODEL IT'S
AN ANTIQUATED MODEL WE ARE.
WE ARE.
PENALIZING PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
THE RIGHT.
THINGS THAT WE'VE WE'VE
ENCOURAGED HIM TO DO IN.
SEOUL THERE ARE TRENDS.
WE GOT TO PAY ATTENTION PEOPLE
AREN'T WEARING WATCHES ANYMORE.
THE SMART PEOPLE ARE NOT WEARING
WATCHES ANYMORE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL USING THEIR
THEIR CELLPHONES IN THE END AND
IN NEWSPAPERS ARE DECLINING AND
SO WE'VE GOT TO START LOOKING AT
SOME OF THESE TRENDS AS WE
GOVERN.
AND PAY ATTENTION SO I'M I'M
SORRY THAT WERE ALWAYS REACTING.
AND CREATING THESE MASSIVE.
DEBATES BUT WE'VE GOT TO START
LOOKING AT THE THIRTY THOUSAND
TITLE MORE AYE.
THAT'S MORE IT'S MORE OF A
STATEMENT WAS CENTER WIENER THAN
A THAN A QUESTION OKAY THEN WILL
COME TO CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PROUD
WATCH WHERE THEY LIKE TO THINK
THAT I LIKE TO THINK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING.
CLOSELY WITH A SENATOR WIENER
AND ONE THING I HAVE.
I'VE LEARNED WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS THAT HE'S A MAN OF HIS
WORD AND I KNOW HE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AND AND ADDRESS
THE ISSUES ESPECIALLY OF
CARSHARING AND CCA'S AND AND I
APPRECIATE TO WORK WITH THEM ALL
THE AMENDMENTS.
BROUGHT FORWARD AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE -- TO MOVE THE BILL
THANK YOU. ONE OF THE QUESTION I
DO HAVE A QUESTION.
I'M SENATOR WHEN ARE YOU OPPOSED
TO CHANGING THE THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT ON THE ON BECAUSE
DO YOU THINK IT MAKES SENSE THAT.
FOR THE CHILI TO PAY A RETAIL
RATE FOR ALSO COMMODITY.
THAT'S WHAT IT NAM CUSTOMERS
REACH OUR OUR REFUNDED AT A
RETAIL RATE VERSUS A WHOLESALE
COMMODITIES THE I. AGAIN AND ASK
MR CONSTANTINE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE -- BECAUSE IT.
KEEPS COMING UP IN TERMS OF THE
ALLEGED CAUTION SO.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
CURTAIL.
THE ABILITY OF THE P. YOU SEE
THE REGULATORS THE BOARDS OF
GOVERNORS THE PIER USE TO CHANGE
THE RATE FOR EXPORTS.
IN FACT IT SPECIFICALLY
ENCOURAGES AND CREATE THE SPACE
FOR THE UTILITIES TO DO JUST
THAT IT.
GIVES DIRECTION TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS ABILITY TO CONSERVE
ENERGY TO DO THE RIGHT THING ON
THEIR PREMISES WITH THEIR ENERGY
AND IT ALLOWS THE REGULATOR.
IN EITHER THE PO YOU ARE THE I.
YOU CASE. TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ABOUT THE VALUE OF
THE EXPORTED ELECTRICITY IN THIS
DOES THIS DOES NOTHING TO SET IN
STONE THE CURRENT FULLY BUNDLED
RETAIL NAM RATE IN FACT IT
EXPRESSLY DOES NOT DO THAT.
SO IT LEAVING THE AUTHORITY
WHERE IT IS APPROPRIATE WHAT IT
IS DOING IS ALLOWING THE
LEGISLATURE TO SPEAK EXACTLY TO
WHAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO DO TO
CONSERVE ENERGY TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION FOR CLIMATE CHANGE.
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THEIR OWN
INVESTMENT DOLLARS TO PROVIDE A
RESOURCE THAT CAN PROVIDE VALUE
TO ALL RATEPAYERS ON THE GRID
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING WE ARE
ASKING CUT CUSTOMERS.
BUSINESSES TO INVEST IN SOLAR
AND STORAGE WE NEED TO CREATE
THE MECHANISMS TO ALLOW THAT
VALUE TO FLOURISH AND SPREAD WE
NEED TO STOP CURTAILING THEIR
ABILITY TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
AND IN FACT WE DON'T DO THAT TO
PUT CUSTOMERS IN VERY SIMILAR
SITUATIONS WHEN YOU PUT A HEAT
PUMP WATER HEATER IN YOUR HOME
AND YOU HAVE THAT TIED TO THE
RATE THAT YOU PAY THE TIME OF
USE RATES.
WHICH WE HAVE DESIGNED. TO ALIGN
YOUR USAGE WITH THE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THE GRIP YOU ARE
USING STORAGE.
WHEN YOU PUT AN EFFICIENT
WINDOWS YOU ARE REDUCING YOUR
DEMAND ON THE UTILITY WE DO NOT
REACH INTO PEOPLE'S HOMES AND
PENALIZE THEM FOR THE?
ENERGY THAT THEY DID NOT USE AND
THAT IS THE CORE PRINCIPLE OF
THIS BILL IT SAYS WE SHOULD NOT
IMPOSE DISCRIMINATORY FEES OR
ARBITRARY ACCESS FEES ON SOLAR
CUSTOMERS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE MAKING
THE RIGHT CHOICE ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC POLICY IT LEAVES UNTIE
REALLY OPEN AN ENTIRELY.
A WIDE RANGE OF POSSIBILITIES
FOR HOW TO ADDRESS COST SHIFT SO
THIS ISSUE OF CAUTION I'M I'M
VERY PLEASED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS IT BUT THE FACT IS THAT
THE BILL DOES NOTHING TO CURTAIL
OUR ABILITY. TO LIMIT COST SHIFT
AND IN FACT PROVIDE THE BENEFIT
TO ALL RIGHT THANK OU AND WE'RE
JUST GONNA CLOSEST NOW AND GO TO
THE CLOSING COMMENTS BUT WELL
THIS BILL DOES -- DOES PROTECT
THE SOLAR CUSTOMERS SAYS WE DO
NOT WANT TO DISCRIMINATORY VISA
DOES NOT PROTECT THE NON.
SOLAR CUSTOMERS SAY WE DO NOT
DISCRIMINATORY FEES AGAINST THEM
SO THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE.
THAT'S THE ESSENCE AND IF WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ONE CUSTOMER WE
SHOULDN'T DISCRIMINATE.
AGAINST ANY THAT IS KIND OF THE
DEBATE THAT WERE.
TRYING TO SETTLE HERE AND WITH
THE OUTCOME OF THIS BILL WE I
WANT ALL REPAIRS TO BE.
PROTECTED IN NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST.
WILL ALLOW YOU TO MAKE YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS STRUCTURE I
JUST WANNA MAKE ONE
CLARIFICATION I USE A LITTLE
HUMOR ON WATCH WHERE SAID I WAS
NOT TRYING TO OFFEND ANYONE.
BUT HAPPY THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME WE SEE THAT BUT BUT
THE DATA SHOWS THE SYSTEMIC
TRAIN IS THAT MILLENNIALS ARE
NOT.
BUYING HERE YOU COME AGAIN I
SURE WINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
AROUND AGAIN THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- FOR THIS THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AS WE COULD SEE FROM
DISCUSSION THE COMMITTEE -- AS
WELL AS THE ROBUST -- PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BOTH SIDES --
OBVIOUSLY THIS THIS ISSUE
MATTERS AND IT MATTERS BECAUSE
AS CENTER MORE LOCK POINTED OUT.
WE'RE IN A PERIOD OF TRANSITION
AND WE WANT PEOPLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO PENALIZE
PEOPLE -- BUT THE REALITY IS.
THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL AND WE
NEED MORE CLEAN ENERGY AND RIGHT
NOW IT IS TOO HARD FOR PEOPLE
AND BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PEOPLE WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING WE SHOULD NOT BE PUTTING
BARRIERS IN THEIR WAY.
AND YES IT IS THE THE TREND
THESE TRANSITIONS ARE NEVER.
EASY.
WE HAVE A CENTRALIZED MONOPOLY
UTILITY MODEL IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH AND WE'VE SEEN WHAT THE
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE OF THAT
AND THERE ARE BENEFITS THEY'RE
ALSO DOCUMENTS AND WE'VE SEEN
SOME OF THOSE DOCUMENTS.
IN WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE WITH
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES BURNING DOUBT --
AND HAVING.
MORE ABILITY TO HAVE
DECENTRALIZED ENERGY GENERATION
HELP OF MANY DIFFERENT -- IN
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS INCLUDING
RESILIENCY AND INCLUDING NOT
HAVING TO BUILD AS MANY
TRANSMISSION PROJECTS WHICH IS
DIRECTLY INCREASES RATES FOR
RATE PAYERS WHEN YOU HAVE.
TO OVER AND OVER AGAIN WE KNOW
THE HISTORY OF THOSE PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALRIGHT SO THIS IS A TRANSITION.
PROTECT PEOPLE WORKING TO DO
THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY -- WE
HAVE A MOTION.
I CENTER STONE.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
D. PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO HI WITH
SO I MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
CHIANG DIED.
DIED AYE HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER
AYE STERN STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
IT WILL HOLD A ROOM FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR.
ARE WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM CENTER
MORE WORK [inaudible]
THIS IS.
NOT THE NOT THESE. TEN MINUTES
TOPS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] THIRTY OKAY.
I NEED TO RUN A COUPLE RENTS
NOMINAL [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR ALL
THAT YOU'RE DOING.
TO REDUCE FUTURE WILDFIRES --
FROM OCCURRING ESPECIALLY
WILDFIRES INSTIGATED BY SPARKING
ELECTRIC LINES.
COLLEAGUES THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ALREADY HAVE SPECIAL
FUNDS. FOR DRESSING OVERHEAD
POWER LINES. FOR PURPOSES OF
UNIFICATION KNOWN AS REAL TWENTY
A AND ALSO BE AND SEE.
THE GOAL OF SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
IS TO BETTER UTILIZE THESE FUNDS
FOR THE AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK HERE. THREE TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS OF PEOPLE
ON PEOPLE AND PROPERTY FROM
CHILE ASSOCIATED WILDFIRES.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
PROVIDE FOR MATCHING FUND
OPPORTUNITIES ALLOWING I USED TO
PARTNER WITH WILLING COMMUNITIES.
FOR CONVERSION PROGRAM TO
UNDERGROUNDCERTAIN ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
FUNDING WOULD ALSO BE MADE
AVAILABLE FROM THE G. G. R.
AFTER GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
MISTER CHAIR THE COMMITTEE HAS
REQUESTED I CONSIDER A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE AND
COUNSEL ON THIS BILL.
LET ME ADDRESS EACH
RECOMMENDATION IN THE ORDER
GIVEN IN THE STAFF REPORT.
REGARDING G. G. R. F.
APPROPRIATIONS OF A SPECIFIC
DOLLAR AMOUNT I ACCEPT THAT
AMENDMENT.
TIER -- THREE THIS SURVEY KICK
THEIR PATIENTS FIND. THREE
REALLOCATION PROTOCOLS ARE ALSO
ACCEPTABLE.
THERE WERE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
TO SECTION ONE OF SECTION SEVEN
ONE EIGHT TEN THE COMMITTEES
CONSULTANTS.
IS A FIERCE BUT FAIR NEGOTIATOR.
SO I WILL ALSO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN UP IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR WITH A WILLING
COMMUNITY SOME MODIFIED
PROVISIONS MAY HAVE.
COMMUNICATED THE WRONG CONCERNS
ON WHAT HAS BECOME A LIFE OR
DEATH MATTER SO CONSEQUENTLY I
APPRECIATE ALL THE GIVE AND TAKE
THAT.
HAS BEEN PROVIDED ON ASSISTING
US ON THIS BILL.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES A
PROFESSIONAL FRAMEWORK OF
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE CLIENT
COMMUNITY AN ELECTRIC UTILITY
PROVIDER.
IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE.
UTILITIES WHO LEARNED HARD
LESSONS TWO DECADES AGO THEY
HAVE BEEN HARDENING ASSETS
METHODICALLY OVER THE PAST
TWENTY PLUS YEARS.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR CONTINUES
THE SEPARATE WITH A METHOD TO
EXPEDITE SMART TRANSMISSION OF
POWER IN THE SAFEST
COLLABORATIVE MANNER.
AND I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
COUNCILMAN BOB WILL IN LAGUNA
BEACH AND FORMER MAYOR RICK
MULLIN FROM.
MALIBU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
pBIG IN SUPPORT OF US SB FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR I WANT TO START UP
BY THINKING CENTER MORE LOCK AND
HIS STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE ON THIS BILL.
I WAS IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE
<c.red>N TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WAS</c>
SENATOR MORE LOCK -- HONEST BE
FOURTEEN SIXTY THREE IT WAS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND UNFORTUNATELY
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR BUT
SENATOR MORE LAW CAN I IN LIGHT
OF THE DEVASTATION THAT OCCURRED
THE LAST TWO YEARS STATE WHY DO
TO WILD FIRES CAUSED BY
UTILITIES.
YOU KNOW WE GREW THE NEW
LEGISLATION IS HERE SO I'M BACK
BEFORE YOU AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
WE'RE GONNA BEACH IS A SMALL
COMMUNITY IN A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS BUT WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX MILLION VISITORS A
YEAR.
WE'RE SURROUNDED BY SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN SPACE 85%
OF OUR COMMUNITY IS HERE IS HERE.
IS BY FAR SEVERITIES ON 55% HERE.
THREE WE ONLY HAVE THREE WAYS IN
AND OUT OF TOWN.
OF BOTH STATE HIGHWAYS PACIFIC
COAST HIGHWAY AND STATE ROUTE
ONE THIRTY THREE BETTER KNOWN TO
US AS LAGUNA CANYON ROAD.
WHICH IS A WINDING ROAD ORDERED
BY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
UTILITY POLES.
WE'VE EXPERIENCED OVER SIXTY
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS SO -- VEHICLE
VERSUS POLAND THAT ROAD IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS CLOSING THE ROAD
ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS.
YES I HAVE AS MANY OF DONE IN
JANUARY OF VISITED PARADISE TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN LEARN FROM THE
DISASTER THERE THAT APPLIED TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
PARADISE LIKELY GONNA BEACH
SUFFERED FROM LIMITED INGRESS
AND EGRESS.
I SPOKE TO THE CAL FIRE INCIDENT
COMMANDER WHO WAS ON THE SCENE
THAT MORNING AND HE SAID THAT
DOWN UTILITY LINES AND POLES
WERE HUGE PROBLEM ON THE
EVACUATION.
EFFORT.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHILE
FAR AS WE KNOW WAS ONE OF THE IT
WAS THE ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
CAL FIRES DETERMINE THAT AT
LEAST NINETEEN WILDFIRES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WERE
CAUSED BY UTILITY LINES AND
EQUIPMENT CAMPFIRE.
IS NOT BEEN FINALLY DETERMINED
BUT P. JEANNIE HAS SAID IT'S
PROBABLE THAT IT WAS THEIR
EQUIPMENT THE COST IT.
THESE YOU KNOCK ON UNDER
GROUNDING THAT YOU ALWAYS HEAR
IT FROM UTILITY COMPANIES OTHERS
AND OTHERS IS THAT IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE.
THIS IS A SHORT SIGHTED ANALYSIS
THE FOCUSES ONLY ON THE UP FRONT
COST.
WOULD YOU WHEN YOU FACTOR IN THE
HUMAN LOSS THE PROPERTY DAMAGE
THE HEALTH HAZARDS AND COST THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE TO WATER
RESOURCES FORCE AN OPEN SPACE.
THE MOUNTAINS OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
CREATED THE GREENHOUSE GASES
EMITTED FROM ONE MAJOR WILDFIRE
OFFSETS A WHOLE YOU A YEAR
PRODUCTIONS.
YOU BEGIN TO REALIZE THE TRUE
COST OF UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES.
BY RELOCATING THE UTILITY POLES
UNDERGROUND AT YOUR THREE ZONES
WE'RE INVESTING IN SMART
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT LOOKS TO THE
FUTURE -- MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
ABSORBING THE COST OF UTILITY
BECAUSE WILD FLOWERS TO UTILITY
RATES.
I AND HIGHER INSURANCE RATES.
WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT WILL HOLD
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE EXPEDITE
UNDERGROUND IN PROJECTS.
IMPACTED JURISDICTIONS AND
DEVELOP A FAIR FUNDING MECHANISM
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO ASK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK ON
OPPOSE.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HEY
WE HAVE.
ONE OKAY SIR TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S RICK MAMA COUNCILMEMBER
FOR THE CITY OF MALIBU AND
CAPTAIN IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT ALTHOUGH
NOT HERE SPEAKING FOR THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT I AM HERE TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE FIVE EIGHTY FOUR NOVEMBER --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE'LL SEE
FIRE.
THE LARGEST FIRE IN LA COUNTY
HISTORY SWEPT THROUGH AND AREN'T
NEARLY AS HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
DESTROYED MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOMES KILLED THREE
PEOPLE.
AND PROMPTED EVACUATION OF
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
ON THAT DAY I WAS THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY AS WELL AS AN ACTING
FIRE CAPTAIN IN MY TRIP WHICH IS
A HEAVY EVER BRUSH AREA OF SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS.
WAS PARTICULARLY DEVASTATED WITH
60% OF THE HOMES DESTROYED START
ON THE EASTERN END OF MY TWENTY
SQUARE MILE DISTRICT AS THE
FIFTY FOOT WALL OF FLAME.
SWEPT THROUGH AND MANAGED TO
SUCCESSFULLY SHELTER IN PLACE
BUT AS WE TRY TO DO FIRE.
FOR FOLLOW THE FIRE WHICH IS A
NORMAL FIRE DEPARTMENT TACTIC
WE'RE IMPEDED WITH OUR MOBILITY
I ALL THE DOWN FIRE POLLS
SIXTEEN HUNDRED OF WHICH HAD
EVENTUALLY BE REPLACED. FOR THE
PAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS
AGREEMENT OWNED BY CALIFORNIA'S
THREE LARGEST UTILITIES.
UNITED MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
FIRES ACROSS THE STATE TURNING
OFF POWER DURING HIGH WINDS
MANAGING VEGETATION HARDENING
POWER LINES ARE JUST NOT ENOUGH.
IN THE HIGH RISK FIRES SINCE
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IS NOTED THAT
THESE MEASURES ARE ONLY 60% OF
THE ACTIVE IS PUTTING.
OVERHEAD SYSTEMS INTO THE GROUND.
FOR THOSE MUNICIPAL
MUNICIPALITIES LOCATED IN TIER
THREE FIRE THREATS THAT ARE
EXTINCT EXTREME FIRE RISK IS
DESIGNATED BY THIS CP UC'S FIRE
TH.
MAP THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE NEED.
THE HIGHER HELP UNDERGROUND
ELECTRICAL LINES WERE FEASIBLE
AND PREFERRED.
CATASTROPHIC FIRES FROM
DESTROYING LIVES STRUCTURES AND
HABITAT SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
UPDATE RULE.
TWENTY THE OVERHEAD CONSERVATION
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN LARGELY
UNCHANGED SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE BILL WILL INCLUDE
ELIGIBILITY WITHIN RULE TWENTY
FOR UNDERGROUND FOR AWHILE FOR
MITIGATION ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION SPECIFICALLY AND LOOK.
ACTIONS LOCATED IN TIER THREE
FIRE THREAT AREAS WHERE FEASIBLE
AND PREFERRED.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO NOT
[inaudible]
TO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMES JACK
ON BEHALF OF CAL TELL.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OPPOSED
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE A CONCERN -- FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE COMMITTEE --
THESE POLLS IN ADDITION TO
CARRYING THE STATE'S OWER
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO CARRY THE
STATE'S COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS CRITICAL
TO PROVIDING HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND NINE ONE ONE ACCESS
AND THE LIKE -- UNFORTUNATELY
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS HAVE NO
COST RECOVERY MECHANISM AS IT
RELATES TO UNDERGROUND IN
PROJECTS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
RULE TWENTY FUNDS AND ARE
PROHIBITED FROM PASSING.
THESE THE COST OF UNDER
GROUNDING ANSWER CHARGES -- TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS AND SO OFTEN
TIMES WHEN RULE TWENTY PROJECTS
ARE APPROVED -- COMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS GIVEN THE VERY HIGH
COST UNDERGROUND OFTENTIMES HAVE
TO JUST DISCONNECT SERVICE TO
THAT UNDERGROUND IT -- PORTION
OF CONDUIT -- AND SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
UNDERGROUND AND BILLS CURRENTLY
IN THE LEGISLATURE IN AND JUST
WANT.
TO URGE BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR -- AS WE HAVE RAISED
THE P. YOU SEE TO CONSIDER
CREATING A COST RECOVERY
MECHANISM FOR THE COMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS WHO SHARE THOSE POLLS.
NEWS TO ME NEVER HEARD THAT
BEFORE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY WE
ALSO DO NOT HAVE A POSITION BUT
PRECIADO -- THE ABILITY TO JUST
MAKE THE COMMENTS THAT WE
APPRECIATE -- THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT -- ON THE BILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE RAISED ON COSTS --
AND FEASIBILITY BUT WE WON IT.
BUT THE AUTHOR ON HIS STAFF AND
COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESS THE BROAD
NATURE OF THE BILL BUT STILL
SUPPORT THE IN -- OF IMPROVING
SAFETY -- IN THIS NEW NORMAL
THANK YOU OKAY VERY WELL OF COME
TO THE MEMBER.
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENT.
I DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS BUT
I'LL MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
WILLOW [inaudible]
MOTION [inaudible]
AND THEN.
AGAIN YOU DID MENTION THE
AMENDMENTS WILLING EXCEPT.
I WENT THROUGH THE WHOLE.
AND AND AND IS THAT A YES YEAH
MY IT MIGHT YOU TWISTED MY ARM
AND I ACCEPTED.
AMENDMENTS MISTER CHAIR.
AND I MOVE THE BILL WITH THE MEN.
THAT I TWISTED HIS ARM TO OBTAIN
OKAY.
CLOSING COMMENTS RIGHT YOUR
CHAIR -- JUSTIN RESPONSE MAYBE
TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
MAYBE YOU KNOW IN THIS
DELIBERATION MAYBE WHAT POLLS --
ART MAY BE A THING OF THE PAST
ME WITHOUT A LOOK AT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I LIKE GUYS STEEL OR SOME OTHER.
YOU KNOW HARDENING OF OF OF
THESE POLL SO THEY DON'T JUST
HAPPEN BREAK AND AND AND
CROSSOVER ROAD SOMETHING. TO
THINK ABOUT -- TO SOME OF THE
MEDICATION CONCERNS.
THEY'RE STILL LIGHT POLES.
AND SO DOES COULD STILL BE
UTILIZED SO THERE'S ROOM FOR
GOOD DEBATE HERE.
MISTER CHAIR AT THE CITY OF
ANAHEIM HAS ITS OWN PUBLIC
UTILITY.
AND THE LAST TWENTY YEARS IT HAS
HARDENED AN UNDERGROUND IT IN
ITS WILDFIRES OWNS IT'S A LONG
TERM PROCESS.
BUT IN TWENTY YEARS THEY HAVE
TAKEN CARE OF 98% OF THEIR
WILDFIRE AREAS WITH THAT WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TO TO COLLABORATE
TOGETHER SO I THINK THIS IS A
WIN WIN.
AND REQUEST AND I THANK YOU SIR --
OKAY -- WE HAVE A MOTION THIS
CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASSED TO BE AMENDED IN
NATURAL RESOURCES IN WATER HUESO.
I HUESO I MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD CHIANG
DIED.
HERTZBERG ILL MCGUIRE RUBIO
SKINNER.
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN STONE
WIENER
.
WE ARE NOW ADDRESSING SENATE
BILL SEVEN ZERO EIGHT BY SENATOR
HUESO AND YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU -- I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR LET ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN NO.
THAT IS INTENDED TO HAVE --
PUBLIC DISCUSSION ABOUT.
OF PROVIDING MORE TRANSPARENCY
TO THE PUBLIC IN A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OPERATIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR.
OTHER CUTS WAS OFTEN A CONFUSED
AS A STATE AGENCY ALTHOUGH IT IS
NOT.
HOWEVER IT IS AN AGENCY THAT WAS
CREATED BY STATE STATE STATUTE.
IT IS A NON PROFIT THAT IS
GOVERNED BY -- CALIFORNIA STATE
LAWS.
AND THEY ARE.
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE
OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HI SO MANAGES THE FLOW OF THE
ELECT HE CROSSED THE HIGH
VOLTAGE BOUGHT OLD.
OUR SYSTEM THAT MAKES UP 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
AND A SMALL PART OF NEVADA
SELECTRIC READ.
IT IS ALSO REGISTERED BOTH IT'S
A TRANSMISSION OPERATOR AND
BALANCING AUTHORITY.
AND THERE ARE EVEN PROPOSALS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT ARE
CONSIDERING GIVING CHI SO
GREATER.
FLEXIBILITY IN MANAGING IN THE
GRIP.
OR GREATER AUTHORITY OVER MEN
MANAGING THE BREAD.
ALSO WITH OTHER BALANCING
AUTHORITIES THE THE CHI SO IS.
BURKE AND ARE REGULATED AS TO A
FEDERAL AGENCIES THAT OVERSEE
THEIR OPERATIONS.
THIS.
IMPLIES THAT THERE IS.
GOVERNMENT A GIVER GOVERNMENT
REGULATORY INTERVENTION ANY TIME
THE GOVERNMENT IS INVOLVED IN.
REGULATING AN ORGANIZATION OF
COURSE.
A GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
KNOWLEDGE JUST.
TO THE WHAT IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING INTERNALLY AND AND THE
SYSTEM DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
COMES IMPORTANT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN RECENT YEARS THERE'S ALSO
BEEN A INCREASED ATTENTION TO
THE ROLE OF THE CLEAN ABATE.
DEBATE ABOUT EXPAND ITS GREAT
OPERATIONS TO OTHER STATES AND
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES IF
PEOPLE WERE. TWO YEARS IT'S BEEN
KIND OF A DISCUSSION.
ADDITIONALLY OUR RECENT ACTIVITY
CONCERNING THE CHI SO HAS
FURTHER INCREASE THE DESIRE. TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CAUSE TO
OPERATION THESE INCLUDE.
PROPOSALS TO HAVE THE CHI SO
PROCURE RESOURCES INCLUDING A
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR [inaudible]
MEGAWATTS.
A PUP STORAGE. TO A FIRST OF ITS
KIND TRANSMISSION ACCESS CHARGE.
AND THE AREA ALSO THE INCREASED
USE OF BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT BY
THE CHI SO FOR RESOURCE ADDICT.
AND ALSO THE CONTINUED EXPANSION
OF THE CRISIS ENERGY IMBALANCE
MARKET.
AND ALSO THE REPLACEMENT OF PIC
RELIABILITY COORDINATED SERVICES
WITH THOSE OF THE CHI SO.
THESE AND OTHER ISSUES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE TO MY AND
MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
DESIRE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND.
THE CHI SOS OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY INTENDED.
AS AN EFFORT AGAIN AS A DIALOGUE
OF WHICH OF THESE AND OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THIS UP IN A BILL --
OF THIS BILL SHOULD APPLY TO THE
OPERATIONS OF THE CHI SO.
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO APPLY.
MANY PROVISIONS OF OF CURRENTLY
OF THAT ARE CURRENTLY PLOP PLIED
TO ANY STATE AGENCY INCLUDE
INCLUDING OPEN MEETINGS ACT.
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
OVERSIGHT OF THE BUDGET AND
AUTHORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONDUCT.
AN AUDIT.
ALL IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS THERE IS
NO REASON WHY WE COULDN'T
REQUIRE THAT OF CHI SO.
AND AGAIN IF THE PUBLIC AND OF
THIS LEGISLATURE WOULD BE BETTER
SERVED.
AT HAVING MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW ON AGENCY THERE SO ESSENTIAL.
TO OUR GREAT OPERATIONS.
B. IS RUN. ONE AREA THAT WE WILL
BE DEFINITELY ADDRESS IN IS THE
NEED TO LIMIT THE DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION.
WHICH MAY BE MARKET SENSITIVE
THAT IS ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT OF
OF HEAVEN ANY ORGANIZATION THAT
HANDLES SENSITIVE.
INFORMATION THAT'S CRITICAL.
TO ESTABLISH SHE IN.
OUR RATES PROTECTING RATES FOR
THE BENEFIT OF RATE PAYERS.
I HAVE WELCOME -- TO THESE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CHI SO AS
TO HOW THEIR CURRENT POLICIES IN
OPERATIONS MAY SATISFY SOME OF
THE PROPOSED REQUIREMENTS.
THEY ARGUE THAT THEY DO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC SO --
IN IN THIS PROCESS I DON'T SEE
WHY APPLYING ANY OF THOSE.
PROVISIONS TO THE CARS SO WOULD
IMPEDE THEIR ABILITY TO OPERATE
THE ENERGY -- DE CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY COMMISSION HANDLE HANDLE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION AND THAT
INFORMATION.
IS PROTECTED AS PROPRIETARY FOR
SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THEY REGULATE.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE CAN
ALSO PROVIDE.
THAT SAME.
PROTECTION.
TO THE PROCESS OF OF OF OF
TRADING IMBALANCE IN THE BREAD
AND AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE CONTINUE TO BE EFFECTIVE AT
PERFORMING THE ROLE.
AND YOU HAVE THE LESS IS I I I
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE I HAVE
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY OF OF THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
OF ORGANIZATION SO WE HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES ARE MAKES BRIEF
COMMENTS -- THANK YOU SENATOR.
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK AS THE
CHAIR POINTS OUT IN HIS
STATEMENT THE CALIFORNIA EYES SO
IS PLAYING AN INCREASINGLY
CENTRAL ROLE.
IN MANY STATE POLICIES AND THE
EXECUTION OF OUR LONG TERM
RESOURCE PLANNING AND
RELIABILITY GOALS ON AND IT MAY
BE TAKING ON NEW RESPONSE.
THAT EXTEND ITS INVOLVEMENT
INCLUDING ITS INVOLVEMENT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW RESOURCES
THAT OPERATE ON THE SYSTEM IN
THAT.
IN THAT FRAME WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
CONSIDER MODEST REFORMS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL.
THAT WOULD ASSIST THE I SO AS A
CALIFORNIA NON PROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION CARRY OUT
ITS FUNCTIONS IN A MANNER
CONSISTENT WITH STATE POLICY.
WE'RE PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE I SO
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED INFORMATION
RELATING TO SANCTIONS FOR
VIOLATIONS OF EXISTING TERRACE
OR RULES OF CONDUCT BY MARKET
PARTICIPANTS WERE SCHEDULING
COORDINATORS.
THE I SO CURRENTLY ROUTE I
REFUSES TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE THE
NAMES OF COMPANIES THAT VIOLATE
ITS RULES OF CONDUCT CLAIMING
THAT THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
IDENTITIES OF THESE.
COMPANIES WOULD REPRESENT PUBLIC
SHAMING AND BECAUSE REPUTATIONAL
HARM TO THE MARKET PARTICIPANTS.
I ASK YOU HOW THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD RESPOND IF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WERE TO
REFUSE TO DISCLOSE THE
IDENTITIES OF ENTITIES THAT IT
HAD SANCTIONED FOR VIOLATING ITS
RULES.
I'M NOT SURE THAT WOULD GET VERY
FAR IN THE LEGISLATURE.
ARE WE DISAGREE WITH THE I. ESOS
OUR PRACTICE AND WE THINK THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IS BEST SERVED
BY DISCLOSING BASIC INFORMATION.
ABOUT THAT ABOUT ALL VIOLATIONS
THAT RESULT IN FINANCIAL
PENALTIES.
WE ALSO BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING FULL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT AND THE
BAGLEY KEENE OPEN MEETINGS ACT --
CURRENT LAW ONLY REQUIRES
ADHERENCE TO GENERAL POLICIES OF
THESE ACT AND WE THINK THAT THE
I ESOS CURRENT POLICIES.
WHICH ARE WEAKER THAN THOSE THAT
APPLY TO STATE AGENCIES --
SHOULD BE BROUGHT UP TO SPEED --
AT AND CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
THAT APPLY TO ANY STATE AGENCY.
SO TAKEN TOGETHER WE THINK THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL SHOULD
RESULT IN CLOSER WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE I SO.
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES THANK
YOU.
THE TERM REMEMBER SCOTT WHICH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES A
CALIFORNIA C. PATRIOTS COUNCIL
TO SEE A CESSATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE WESTERN CITY
COUNCIL.
SHEET METAL WORKERS.
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL CAL I
SO IS A PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNED BY.
THE LAW OF CALIFORNIA IT SPENDS
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
REPAIR MONEY IN AUTHORIZES THE
EXPENDITURE OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF REPAIR MONEY.
WE BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE THE
PUBLIC DESERVES TO BE ABLE LOOK
AT THE DOCUMENTS AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND THE THINGS
THAT THEY USE AS A BASIS FOR
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS WE THINK
THEY SHOULD COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE ONCE A YEAR.
SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE HOW
THEY'RE SPENDING THOSE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF REPAIR
FUNDS.
THEY POINT TO THEIR EXISTING
RULES AND REGULATIONS AND SAY
THAT THOSE ARE SUFFICIENT.
BUT THOSE ARE SELF GOVERNED THEY
CAN CHANGE THE MOOD ANYTIME.
THEIR THEIR OWN SELF ENFORCER SO
WE BELIEVE IN INSTITUTIONALIZING
THESE BLUE SKY TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS.
AND IN HAVING THE LEGISLATURE
TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
LOOKING AT THE OPERATIONS OF
CALLOUS SO IS COMPLETELY
RESPONSIBLE.
AND WE WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
STRETCH ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
BORN COMMON THE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS.
I GUESS MISTER CHAIR -- THIS IS
FEEL PAIN GO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
I SO -- WE'RE NOT IN OPPOSITION
BILL IN FACT TAKEN A POSITION
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME
INFORMATION MY MY SHARE THEN.
THANK YOU NAME AGAIN.
OF PHIL PATTON GIL I'M A
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR.
AND AS I SHARED.
WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION THE BILL
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME
INFORMATION FIRST WHAT I LIKE TO
THINK THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF --
FOR ALREADY GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS BUT
WHAT I WANTED TO DO TODAY WAS
BRING TO YOU SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT OUR COURT PRACTICE.
PROCEDURES DO CREATE AND SATISFY
THE DESIRE FOR TRANSPARENCY
THAT'S IN THIS BILL BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO CONTINUE THAT
DIALOGUE AND DISCUSSION.
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS JUST
SHARE WITH YOU SOME KEY
INFORMATION.
FIRST OF ALL WE DO REALLY PRIDE
OURSELVES AS A PUBLIC ASSESSABLE
ORGANIZATION AND THERE'S THREE
MAIN ACTIVITIES AND PROCESS SEES
THAT WE HAVE THAT I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU.
FIRST OF ALL ALL OF OUR BOARD
MEETINGS ARE OPEN PUBLIC
SESSIONS AND ANY DECISIONS BY
THE I. SO BORED ARE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC AND RECEIVE COMMENT AND
FEEDBACK FROM THE PUBLIC AT THAT
TIME.
THE RECORDS AVAILABILITY OF ACT
WAS MENTIONED AND WE HAVE A VERY
CLEAR RECORDS AVAILABILITY
POLICY YOU WERE ANYONE IN THE
PUBLIC CAN COME TO THE I. SO.
AND REQUEST INFORMATION AND WE
RISK.
IN TAKE TEN DAYS SO WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF OUR A WILLINGNESS TO BE
ACCOMMODATING AND TIMELY IN
THOSE RESPONSES.
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE A VERY
INCLUSIVE STAKEHOLDER POLICY
PROCESS.
AND WHAT WE DO IN THAT POLICY
PROCESS IS GO THROUGH A FAIRLY
REGIMENTED PROGRAM WHERE WE LAY
OUT AN ISSUE RECEIVE COMMENTS.
PUBLISHED THOSE COMMENTS AND
CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH THAT
DIALOGUE UNTIL WE CAN RECONCILE
SOMETHING TO BRING ULTIMATELY TO
THE I. SO BOARD FOR APPROVAL AND
THAT PUBLIC PROCESS THEIR
MENTION. ONE OF THE EXAMPLES OF
THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT WE
USE IS IN FACT HOW WE APPROVE
OUR ANNUAL BUDGET.
SO WE OPEN UP THE STAKEHOLDER
INITIATIVE RECEIVE COMMENTS AND
FEEDBACK FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC.
AND THEN ULTIMATELY BRING THAT
BUDGET TO THE I. SO BOARD FOR
APPROVAL [inaudible]
SO.
I WANTED TO SHARE THE ISSUE
ABOUT SOME OF THESE MAJOR
INITIATIVES BECAUSE ONE OF THE
GOOD THINGS ABOUT OUR BUDGET IS
WE HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN OUR BUDGET.
CHANGE LESS THAN 1% SINCE THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN IN
EACH IN EACH YEAR AND YET WE
STILL BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT SOME
MAJOR INITIATIVES -- BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS AND ONE OF THOSE IS
THE WESTERN.
ENERGY BOUNCE MARKET.
AND WITHOUT MARKET WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WORKED WITH WESTERN
STATE IN CALIFORNIA TO ACTUALLY
SEE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER SAY
ALMOST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SINCE.
TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT IN ADDITION
THAT REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
SO AGAIN THE BILL ANALYSIS
REFLECTS THAT IT'S IT'S YOU GUYS
SO THE COMPLICATED ORGANIZATION
YOU HEARD SOME OF THAT ALREADY
THIS MORNING FROM FROM.
FROM THE AUTHOR AND THAT IS THAT
WE ARE A NONPROFIT FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE ORGANIZATION BUT WE'RE
ALSO REGULATED REGULATED BY.
FOR THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED
TO DO IS MAKE SURE WERE
COMPLIANT WITH THOSE FEDERAL
STANDARDS AND OBLIGATIONS AND
SOME OF THAT WILL DICTATE ANY
INFORMATION EXCLUDED THE
DISCLOSURE THAT WE CAN DO.
OUR ENFORCEMENT FOR EXAMPLE IS
UNDER FOR JURISDICTION.
SO ANY RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE I.
SO BECAUSE WE FIND UNDO BEHAVIOR
IN OUR MARKETS ULTIMATELY GETS
REPORTED TO FOR FOR THAT -- THAT
FINAL ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE THE ALSO A NONPROFIT
CORPORATION.
AND SO AS AN ASSOCIATE
NECESSARILY WE NEED TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE RULES
THANKS FOR ALL RAP HERE IN JUST
SECONDS. ONE OF THE THINGS SO
THAT I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU
IS THAT WE CONTINUALLY WORK WITH
STATE AGENCIES IN PROVIDING
INFORMATION.
AS THEIR IMPLEMENTING THE
POLICIES AND IN PARTICULAR THEIR
ADOPTED BY THIS LEGISLATURE AND
SO OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
IMPLEMENTING OUR PS AND SOME OF
THE MORE -- AMBITIOUS ENERGY
POLICIES HAVE BEEN FRONT AND
CENTER FOR US.
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS WRAP
BY SAYING JUST WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE THINGS WE
ARE DOING.
AN ENGAGING HERE AND CERTAINLY
THEN I'LL STOP HERE AND INVITE
ANY QUESTIONS BUT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS.
THANKS FOR COMING ANY QUESTIONS.
MY COLLEAGUES.
YOU HAVE A YOU'VE ANSWERED ALL
THE QUESTIONS I THINK I I WAS
GOING TO ASK TO BUT YOU HAVE TO
HOLD CLOSE SESSIONS WHICH THEN.
WITH THE LIMIT TO THE
INFORMATION OF WHO IS BEING
DISCUSSED OR DOES THE AGENDA SAY.
WHAT BERMS ARE BEING DISCUSSED
IN CLOSED SESSION WHICH IS
CUSTOMARY IN?
OTHER MUNICIPAL ACTIVITIES YEAH
THE THE WAY THE PROCESS
BASICALLY WORKS IS WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF MARKET MONITORING
THAT IS ACTUALLY.
REPORTS DIRECTLY TO THE ISO
BOARD AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE THEIR ACTIVITIES ARE
CONFIDENTIAL UNDER RULES THAT
ARE APPLIED BY FIRST.
AND THEY HAVE THE ABILITY THEN
TO DIRECTLY REPORT TO FOR ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT PARTIES THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THESE MARKETS.
ULTIMATELY THE OUTCOME OF THOSE.
DECISIONS BY THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION ARE POSTED
ON THEIR WEBSITE AND THE FIRMS
ARE NOTICED.
IN TERMS OF THEY FOUND WERE
VIOLATING MARKET RULES.
THANK YOU.
NO I SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
DRIVE EMOTION.
I HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
CLOSING COMMENT A SIMPLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ALL RIGHT
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
DO YOU PASSAGE THIS YEAR A
COMMITTEE WEST SO I WAS SO I'M A
LOT [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER
AYE STERN STONE.
STONE NO WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
IT HAS THE VOTES.
OF THE MATTER ON CALL THANK YOU
AND YOU MAY NOW.
HAVE THIS TIME IT WILL THE
WEAPON.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
CALENDAR.
CHIANG AYE HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
L..
RUBIO AYE STERN.
BELIEVE IN A CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO ITEMS TO SP
FOUR SEVEN BY CENTER DOT.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DO HAS TO BE AMENDED IN NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE [inaudible]
NINE ONE MOORLACH [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB TWO EIGHTY BY CENTER
WIENER CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT THAT SIX
ZERO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHANG [inaudible]
CHANG.
HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO
[inaudible]
STERN.
WE REPEAT ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE
UPON A BILL [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO I STERN.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES BUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE ROLE FROM
FROM CITY MEMBERS -- NOW WILL O
TO SB.
FOR BY.
SENATOR MARLATT.
DO YOU PASS TO BE AMENDED IN
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THREE
ZERO BRADFORD.
I CHIANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG KILL.
KILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR ITEM.
FOR RUBIO I STERN.
STONE.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
NOW ITEM FIVE SB SIX SIX TWO BY
SENATOR ARE CHIU LEFT OUT THERE
PLEASE COSTS OF MEMBERS.
DO YOU HAS AMENDED TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
SIX ONE MOORLACH BRADFORD CHANG.
CHANG I HERTZBERG KILL KILL AYE
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
OKAY WELL.
UP TO MEMBERS ON THIS BE -- SIX
SIX TWO BY ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
BRADFORD I HE HERTZBERG MCGUIRE.
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS AGAIN.
THERE IS SB SIX SIX TD PASSES
AMENDED TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE LINE
ITEM.
FIVE I DON'T. FIVE FIVE I FEEL
THAT IS THE HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE.
MORE LOT.
J. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- ITEM SIX SB
SEVEN AWAY BY SENATOR YOURS
TRULY TRULY.
DO YOU PASSED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ONE
MORE LOCK BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER.
WE SKINNER AYE [inaudible]
STERN I STERN I VERY
[inaudible] SEVEN NINE OKAY
WE'RE GONNA START UP AGAIN
[inaudible]
THOSE MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA START FROM ITEM ONE
SP FOUR NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER.
THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HE PASSES AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT ONE MOORLACH HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE.
STERN AYE STERN AYE.
ITEM TWO SP TWO FOUR SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD FULLER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT HAS TO BE AMENDED IN NATIONAL
RESOURCE IN WATER CURRENT VOTE
TEN ONE MOORLACH MCGUIRE.
REALLY CLOSE THE ROLE ON THE
BILL.
THIS IS MIKE WEIR COMING YEAH
OKAY THEN KEEP IT OPEN.
OKAY WILL GUIDE HIM THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER SP.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT DO YOU PASS IS A
MINUTE TEMPER NATION'S CURRENT
ABOUT NINE ZERO BRADFORD
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
STERN AYE STERN AYE.
VERY WELL WILL GO -- TO I DON'T
FOR SB 584% OR MORE LIKE.
DO HAS TO BE AMENDED NATURAL
RESOURCES WATER COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO BRADFORD.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE.
BRADFORD AYE.
STERN AYE STERN AYE STONE -- SB
SIX SIX TO OUR CHIU MET.
OKAY ONLY WITH WIRE.
SO WE GOT.
OKAY WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY HERE.
ALL OF YOU GUYS ARE DONE.
I WOULD BE HUGE [inaudible]
YEAH.
YOUR USERNAME.
AND OR PROTECTION MUCH OF ALL OF
YEAH
.
SENATE MCGUIRE ON ITEM ONE
SKINNER HOW DOES HE VOTE
[inaudible]
HI.
OKAY ON ITEM WIRE I ON IT WILL
CLOSE ROLE IN THAT BILLS OUT EL
ELEVEN TO ONE ITEM TO SB TWO OR
SEVEN MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT LIMóN.
ONE ON ITEM -- THREE SB TWO
EIGHT TWO EIGHT BY CENTER WIENER.
A CINEMA WHERE AYE.
CHOIR I LOVE AND TWO ZERO YEAH
ON ITEM OF FOR BY THE FOUR BY
CENTER MORLOCK.
HI MCGUIRE I THE BILL IS NOW --
SB SIX SIX TWO BY CENTER TO LET
US AND REQUIRE RIGHT MCGUIRE I
THE BILL IS OUT WITH -- ELEVEN
ONE SB SEVEN OH EIGHT CENTER
WEST SO.
SENATE MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN OF COLLEGE
I WAS NOT A PROBLEM I'M PULLING
YOUR NECK I'M FULLY AWARE
EVERYONE.
WE ARE NOW OUR JOURNALISM